the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
tensions are high with everything on the
line at the feed a candidates in madrid
spain desperately trying to catch first
place the remaining contenders are going
all out but facing fierce competition
second place ding loren overpressed
against timor rajab and the azerbaijani
grand master was ready taking advantage
to defeat the chinese superstar
crippling his chances ian napomniachi
looks unstoppable can the reigning
challenger be beaten round 13 of epic
chess coming up next
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to our live
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament
from madrid spain we are in studio
here in saint louis getting ready for
this penultimate round round 13 dorsey
yes sir how's it going wonderful feeling
good after the rest yes yes very much oh
i thought i think everybody needed hello
everybody we're in the championship
rounds but
we think the tournament is all but
decided
nepo
in this moment of a winner take all
challenger yeah he's got it in the bag
we think but is it a winner take all
tournament or a second place going to be
important dorsa tell the viewers there
are current standings after 12 rounds of
play
12 rounds of fun and nepo is running
away with the tournament plus two
over
karu and dingler
who are fighting for second and look at
the fight for
third four uh fourth fifth sorry with
bobby and timor too
yeah it's very very close uh tournaments
considering the pairings which we'll get
to right away and our format dorsa well
the format is a very very special
tournament right so it's eight player
devil round robin meets 120 minutes for
the first 40 moves then players get
another 16 minutes for another 20 moves
and the final 15 minutes plus 30 seconds
for the rest of the game three time
controls of fun fun fun uh no draw
offers before black's 40th move and a
half a million
euros in the prize money not much of a
schedule left nonetheless here it is
dorset we just came back from a rest day
so that's great we have round 13 and 14
today and tomorrow
a very very unlikely playoffs on tuesday
but let's still keep him in mind
well in fact alejandro has a number of
what ifs to decide indeed if there would
be such a thing as a playoff alejandro
good morning nice to see you my friend
good morning yasir good morning dorsa
great to be in the studio as we perhaps
finally take a look at who is going to
be the challenger for the world
championship match
but that's still a what if because we
have different scenarios for you today
in the case that jane pomnyacci wins or
draws today and trust me as an
experienced commentator i have a large
bet on a draw today as nepo is white
against richard rapport he will win the
tournament that is it nobody can catch
him the only way that never can be
caught is if he loses today and loses
tomorrow and still some results have to
go against him but either one of ding or
nakamura has to win both of their games
to catch up with him it cannot be both
because dink plays knockout tomorrow so
the only two players that are two points
away would need to win both of their
games while nepo loses both himself and
still there is a fight for second place
we've been mentioning throughout the
show it's been a topic of discussion
since bangladesh carlson brought it up
will he defend his world championship
title against the winner of the
candidates we don't know yet and if he
doesn't it all goes back to second place
and this is the race for second who
might potentially play yane pognyachi in
the title in case that magnus decides
not to participate in the event here
we're looking at it hikaru nakamura and
dingley with six and a half points are
leading the pack but fabiano caruana and
timur are just half a point behind and
they're facing each other today a
decisive game and that one potentially
might mean that we have a three-way tie
going into the last round in a tie for
second place with daily rent playing
against icarua yes first might be over
but second everything to play for
unpredictable as ever thank you for that
alejandro dorsa
set the table for today's pairings and
what our viewers can expect yes let's go
well
uh the man of the event nepal is playing
rapport
he has white so that'll be interesting
then we have naka versus duda a huge
fight for second fiery job versus sting
another huge fight for second and
vegetable versus carolina a final super
huge fight for potential second every
one of those pairings has an impact on
the first and second places and once
again let's take a look at the money
what are they fighting for dorset oh
just half a million euro
nice
uh they the first place does go home
with the 48 000 euros
second place is 36 000 euros third place
is 24 000 years and keep in mind that
every point does grant the player
extra 7 000 euros
not bad but of course it's all about
becoming the challenger to this man
magnus carlson world champion will face
we think a match to be dirt the site to
be determined in 2023 we expect that
match to be for 2 million euros
will he or won't he play
we've had jonathan tisdale as a guest
and
[Music]
kind of the edge towards the magnus
might not play but we will see and by
chance magnus happens to be in madrid it
seems that there's a blitz tournament
going on
so who knows maybe we'll be able to
catch up with magnus one of these days
and ask him the most salient question
are you ready to play nepo
and what a party it has been in madrid
not just on the board there's been a
spectacular venue throughout all of
these days but it's been so much fun
around it we have ferrugia playing
naruto in this bullet match there had a
blitz tournament check out who played
this blitz tournament yesterday anish
won it
aneesh wanted with seven and a half out
of eight wow over magnus carlson
grand masters like anton guijaro pepe
cuenca was there enigma was there it was
such a tournament and that was just on
the off day the casual walk in the park
and you see magnus carlsen playing a
blitz event which was open by the way
anybody could participate that was a lot
of fun for the rest they they're having
a great time in madrid really a chess
party all throughout
wow
really really wonderful and again when i
look at the photos
of the palace that they're playing in
i'm just seeing some
really
gorgeous photos and every one of them
looks like a postcard you know with this
golden gilded
uh portraits everywhere just just
fantastic fun
it would be a big big round for nepo if
it weren't for the fact that he has a
two-point lead but again that fight for
second
i mean it is such a keen fight
i'm looking at these pairings and i
don't know which one should be our
marquee match-up help me out dorsa what
do you think which game should we focus
upon maybe i should focus on the nepal
game for the first 10 minutes
uh-huh yeah after yesterday's oh well
the day before over and under where a
draw was made between nepo and uh naka
in in eight minutes uh this is their
lifetime score
so nepo has one win rapport has one win
and they have eight draws interesting
wow i had no idea
that their head-to-head matchups had
been so close and of course earlier in
the tournament the first half
napo won
against richie when richie decided as he
stated after the game time to commit
suicide
i refuse the perpetual i insist you win
it's been that kind of tournament
do you think uh rapport learned from his
mistake and he will not do suicide today
consistently
is so far a gone from this tournament we
talk about fight for second place
nobody's talking about richard rapport
exactly he's in the cellar he's in the
seller he is very ready to get out of
madrid nepo has had luck
how does he how he had luck it's the
order of the pairings nothing he could
have done nothing that is just
determined randomly and you just don't
have control over when somebody is going
to mess up in a tournament but it seems
that he gets exactly the moment alireza
he gets alireza right after he tilts
after losing to nakamura he gets richard
when richard's not fighting for anything
anymore with the white pieces if you
want to make a white
piece
draw with the white pieces john showed
that he can do it easily he's had the
ability to take games that potentially
could be dangerous but because his
tournament situation was already so good
he could just draw it out
and he would have janet pognacci with
the white pieces if richie plays e5
guaranteed some sort of four knights
some sort of very quiet type of position
no danger there he plays c5 guarantee
you there will be no open sicilian
there's no reason to test richard
rapport in the open sicilian today so
we're going to have to see what richard
wants to bring into the game
you'd say
he wants to play for a win but
at this point for what
exactly and yan by the way is open one
e4 but no response from richie dorsey
yeah so i have different uh websites and
different views open here is for me and
i'm seeing richard is just sitting back
in the table and he's just looking at
the position he's just deciding
well e4 what do i do
and that's that's the thing what i was
talking about richard has nothing to
play for yeah if richard had something
to play for in this round he would have
prepped all day yesterday yeah right and
he like looks at all of the nepal
variations what happens when you check
out of a tournament it's a rest day you
get your mind out of it you try to come
back to play a normal good game of chess
but you're not spending all of your time
preparing you're not spending that
energy the way you normally would which
is quite logical i mean psychologically
the poor guy isn't really playing for
any of the
um top prizes top prizes so
it's kind of hard to
make that make yourself go like okay i'm
going to prepare like 24 hours i'm going
to just kill the engines and
he did play sicilian
c5 an indication that he's not going to
let nepo have such an easy day today uh
he has been playing the taiman the time
mana variation with e7 e6 but i would
say that this is some kind of indication
that we could get a fight he's also
played zvashnikov remember he's running
up against hikaru which i think napo
will be thrilled to check out because
there are so many forced draws
in this fashion cuff specifically right
there's a lot of variations that if
white knows their stuff
at some point they ask black do you want
to take the repetition or do you want to
just be clearly worse there are many
many lines like that even the sacrifices
on b5 later on for those that are
familiar with this fascinating variation
theory they also tend to
end in forced draws exactly exactly they
might be really cool-looking jobs but
they're still across
true uh i'm trying to think of one of
them and it would probably you want to
play knight a3 first remember the 93 is
important otherwise you get a five
immediately
okay sorry knight a3 b5 pardon me this
is what i was trying to get into
takes
takes
knight d5
and
i remember i think it was a game of
alexis shiroff
where he did some crazy sacrifices on b5
and there was a move
i mean rook four is still the main line
still the main line after all this is
something that's engraved in my memory i
played this as a as a kid yeah and i
thought there's no way i remember this
unless i go through it a hundred times
right so i went through it a hundred
times i played rook a4 on the board
million times i analyzed c4 i analyzed
castle he takes f5 queen h5 all of them
variations and all of them black is okay
and that's still the current state of
theory that rook a4 black is at least
okay perhaps black is pushing for an
advantage okay despite the fact that the
king on d7 which will be on d7 very soon
uh is rather exposed and all these kind
of things the piece ends up being quite
significant
yeah i remember that
there was a number of uh forced draws in
those variations too well
we certainly jumped way ahead there in
our whole discussion of whether or not
nepa will be able to force a draw it
does look for the moment like
well i mean still uh
knight f6 could be a transposition into
especially off and e7 e6 uh
transposition into a time honor that's a
six player
an indication that we're about to see
the sfeshnikov which richard had played
again earlier in the tournament just
wanted to say that also we haven't
none of that oh
four nights classical or nice not the
four nights the classical four knights
is with e6 huh
yeah but four nights is with the east
yeah this one we just called classical
sicilian because bishop g5 leads to the
richter rouser right and the thing about
this particular move order i don't
remember any force draws
in richter rouser there's a it's a game
it goes on it's a fight right but i
don't remember any fourth draws no and i
remember
when he needed to win uh fabi in the
last round
against sergey chose
the sharp uh rouser because of exactly
what you said there was no fortune for
straws that uh
sergey could steer towards so d7 d6
bishop g5
considered
i
am going to say
the best chance to get an advantage
although there are lots of different
moves here too including bishop c4 and i
don't even know
maybe g3 yeah g3 is
currently a move f3's made a bit of a
resurgence as long as bishop e3
comfortable bishop e2 bishop
is a move it's considered wildly
inaccurate in this position
i would think
out of all the responses yeah it doesn't
really cause any trouble for black i
mean to the best of my knowledge bishop
g5 and bishop c4 are just
oh yeah they're by far in our way the
most popular moves bishop b3 of course
has been making a bit of a comeback
allowing the move e5 a lot of people
have been castling long
still whether it's theoretically the
most sound still remains to be seen
bishop g5 is a
a bit of an automatic past a certain
level i'm not saying that bishop b3 or
g3 are really worse moves but bishop g5
has been as played has been
traditionally the most difficult move
for black to face exactly for four or
five decades now guys as much as i love
this rouser i do play it so it will be
great updates for my own openings right
i do have a small
other favorite game in this tournament
so you both know that i'm a huge fan of
four nights right yes and guess what
uh
boy they are really raising yeah so we
do have that going on with alireza and
ding so thank you thank you gentlemen
for having them my four nights happen
another time in this tournament
but the first time it was a pretty
straightforward draw that's why you play
fortnite you get the straightforward not
imagine this game going anywhere
anywhere whatsoever uh it's a known
position oh yes it's a known position of
the four knights we've gotten here
before let's just go very quickly on how
we got here this is the four knights e45
you take on c6 b takes e6 bishop d3 d5
ed modern days everybody castles there's
nothing wrong with actually taking the
pawn immediately right but since people
figured out that it's actually wrong to
take on c6 they just invert inverted the
move order because d6 is actually
extremely dangerous for white oh yes
i've been there castle cd bishop g5 c6
and this is all well known theory knight
of queen f3 bishop d6 we'd reach these
positions in which eventually this
bishop takes on f6 it ruins the pawn
structure but the queens come off you
get a little bit of control over f5 but
when the knight gets there it gets
chopped off by this bishop and then we
have opposite colored bishops and you're
thinking that seems so simplistic
alejandra there's no way that's how
chess works
but that's exactly how this variation
works
you go there you chop this off you chop
that off you go b3 preparing 93 knight
five and then you exchange those guys
and we make a draw the same draw that we
saw in nepo against dingley ren perhaps
the move or is a little bit different
and then as i'm looking at the database
duda dingler and draw rapper dingley
rand draw moses ending the red draw i
mean digler has played this a few times
obviously every single game of his in
this variation has ended in a draw today
i do not expect it to be any different
now coach can you go females back
instead of bishop d6 what about bishop
e7 if if let's say black really does
want to fight for
something is there anything there this
comes back to what hikaru and anish and
a lot of people have been saying about
playing for with black in this
tournament it's not that black doesn't
have opportunities to make games
exciting and interesting they do it so
often i mean we do it at open
tournaments all the time when we play
you know a random 2350
we play something that is perhaps not
theoretical but
keeps winning chances because we're
higher rated we want to win
so in this position if you go something
like bishop e7 yes technically black
still retains more winning chances
you'll get more pieces in but the bishop
is already in a worse diagonal that is
on d6 since bishop f6 is not a threat
that makes your position better as white
you're already making a concession more
or less for free and this is the kind of
things that you'd love to see as the
white side because these players are so
strong they're not going to get
outplayed just because there's a little
bit of a difference they're going to be
happy to see what they think is an
inaccuracy and then capitalize on it and
that's the reason people aren't playing
against nepal with the black when nepo
is white because they brought in a
repertoire that's ultra solid and ultra
drawish with the black side in order to
get good positions in the candidates
it's hard to just cross over into
something completely sharp completely
new when you have don't have proper
preparation everybody here has brought
proper preparation with the white side
bishop b7 is a move it's been played
many times rook fe-1 i mean the game
kind of goes on uh
is it as fully equal as the other one no
but is dingleran really trying to get a
worst position with black also no by the
way the knight did reach f5 as i
predicted bishop said
bishop f5 your key five none of these
moves are new actually yeah duda and
rapport both played against dingley ran
exactly in this position so
i draw headed our way in this one
momentarily we're just gonna have to
wait for the handshake to be honest this
was not the draw that i thought would be
in the first 10 15 minutes i really
thought nepo could grab the draw in like
the first 20 minutes and be out of here
but well now we're getting another
exciting game between nepo and robots
yes
yes uh we will see
what's going on here i just had actually
a question for alejandro in this
variation
i noticed after bishop g5 i mean
by far the most popular move is e7e6
which was played queen d2 a6 castles
bishop d7 on the board
again
many many thousands of games
um
but now i'm i think it was alexi
drev who was making an attempt
at playing the move bishop d7 followed
by a very quick rook c8
and he was getting some really fantastic
positions alejandro but i i i don't know
what's the theoretical
uh state of things with bishop d7 i was
wondering if if richie was going to go
down a rabbit hole that was a little bit
off the beaten track
bishop g7 is actually a fascinating line
i i studied this quite a bit the problem
with this queen d2 rook c8 stuff it
worked for a long time
uh and after castles we had this like
really weird knight takes queen takes
queen a5 exactly the point is that if
you ever go bishop takes f6 you're happy
you you take with the pawn you don't
move the pawn on e7 you just kind of
develop the bishop randomly and because
the pawn is not only seven or not on e6
these two pawns actually end up being
defended for a long time on the other
hand you give up d5 to the night it's
kind of a weird strategical battle and i
think eventually white is better
theoretically
but people figured out
not that long ago that bishop d7 queen
d2 rook c8 only has one idea that you're
going to take on d4 right and then
people started playing knight b3 and
they say haha you don't have a night too
you don't have a knight to trade
and it was it was not the top engine
move for a very long time
until somebody figured it out and
they're like oh actually this is very
unpleasant
because you don't have a good way of
developing your uh your pieces you could
go back to the e6 castle variations
right but in those positions rook c8 and
knight b3 it's more useful to have
knight v3 than rc8 the rook doesn't
always want to go to c8 it's an open
file but many cases and when the knight
comes to b3 your counter play actually
involves a5 a4
no not really possible in this position
you already put your rook on c8 it's not
that it's refuted or anything like that
right but
theoretically speaking bla white does
get between a slide and a clear
advantage in this kind of position
specifically specifically because they
moved the knight to b3 early i hope i
didn't ruin this variation for too many
yeah
because not a lot of white players know
this you know everybody castles kind of
automatically right and
it's fine if you know if you go down the
theory it's still fine but it gives
black exactly the type of positions they
want to play whereas knight b3 keeps an
advantage in the type of positions black
doesn't want to play
wonderful absolutely fascinating thanks
for that
reveal
even though everybody hates your guts
from that one
i want to turn our attention to a game
that i think uh wow has a lot of
ramifications for our tournament and
that of course is the game between karu
who's coming into today's round tied for
second with ding loren who appears in
our eyes on a certainty
of making a draw against nepal which
would open up the door
however briefly for hikaru to slide
through if he could win
today's game against yan and uh
duda dude is offering a naidorf and
bishop g5 mainline night off but bishop
e3 is what
icaru
used earlier in the tournament to beat
farrugia yes so this will certainly not
have come as a surprise to
duda bishop e3 e5 f3 interesting another
knight f3 exactly bishop e7 now i think
for ruja
alejandra is going to have to help me
actually went knight c6 and got himself
a little trouble bishop e7 is by far the
main line
h2 h3 okay just stopping any pretense of
knight g4 even bishop g4 and in the
future world setting up a a
stage for where you might play g4
kick this knight away from
f6 so that we could
land nicely with knight d5
h6
these are like some very cagey
opening moves that i'm sure have been
engine approved bishop c4 bishop e6 and
we've caught up to date with our players
alejandro
jump right in tell us what the
um
theoretical
knowledge
is of this moment it's very rare yasser
i want to tell you why the move h3 here
almost never essayed the whole point of
this variation with bishop e7 is that
since you have the ability to go bishop
c4 right away and at the moment knight
g4 is not really a move you could play
knight g4 but
taking the time to take on e3 in this
particular position is not that great
prohibitions yes but what is white's
play look bishop on c4 the knight on c3
the knight on f3 so it's not on the way
they're targeting the d5 square right
the d5 square is currently being
targeted knights ac3
feel free to take that bishop i'm gonna
defend it with either knight d5 so i can
take on e3 or queen d to queen e2 just
so i can take with the queen i don't
ruin my pawn structure have a blast with
your pair of bishops the position is not
going to get opened i have a lot of
control in the light squares not really
a threat so everybody plays bishop b7
and nobody play oh sorry bishop c4 and
nobody plays knight g4 right h3 is a bit
of a weird move in my opinion
it does allow the move bishop e6
which just counters this idea of bishop
c4 i assume because the engines are
telling me because it's played a couple
of times that here hikaru had prepared
the move g4
and then we would have gone on for some
wild stuff who knows but duda didn't
seem faced by this decision of playing
h3 he said you played h3 i play h6 no
problem h6 is also a useful move for
black you never know when knight g5 is
coming you never know when this bishop
is going to change its mind and actually
be the one that spends the tempo right
to capture this knight on f6 remember
this battle over the d5 square so duda
didn't want to see any g4 stuff coming
g4 is playable again but i don't think
it's as good i guess the move h6
especially when you can play b5 and
bishop b7 target this pawn on e4 thank
you for the diagonal so we have this
position after h6 the car plays the move
bishop c4 and we kind of go into normal
variations in which we're going to have
to ask ourselves who benefits more from
h3 and h6
not so clear to me after the move bishop
e6 it's already a position that's brand
new in the database
even though we just have the inclusion
of these moves this this is more or less
well known had he gone bishop c4 and the
move bishop e6 not the most popular
usually newcastle but bishop e6 is
perfectly good move in this position
it's been seen by a ton of good not good
amazing night or players gary ronyan
gears play this like four or five times
so clearly a variation now if we throw
in the moves h three and h6 it's the
position that we get where hikaru goes
bishop e6 bishop b3 now does this favor
black or does it favor white my original
impression would be that it favors black
it must favor black because
knight g5 and bishop g5 are much more
assailant in this position than knight
g4 or bishop g4 now that being said it
does give white a hook to go g4 g5 in
certain locations does this change the
character the position it must slightly
i don't know exactly how it's going to
benefit white just yet but hikara is
going to have to exploit it somehow if
he goes for some kind of timid short
castle and then rookie 1 and slow
maneuvering i have the impression that
h6h3 favors black right but if he goes
for something a little crazier where he
plays an early knight h4net f5 and tries
to take advantage of the fact that the
pawns are here perhaps it ends up
favoring white so you're gonna see this
battle between both players trying to
determine whether this little subtlety
is actually going to change the game and
this is their head to head in classical
chess they drew their match up in round
seven to finish up the first half of the
event it's one win for hikaru i'm gonna
have to look at where that one was but
not a lot of experience between these
two players jan shishtof duda is not
only a very young competitor but he
broke into the elite of chess not that
long ago
so hikaru still doesn't have that
experience playing against the polish
superstar
uh bishop b3 knight c6 on the board and
once again you're saying the inclusion
of the moves h3 h6 very unusual uh let's
take those moves h3 and h6 back for a
moment
alejandro and follow some games if we
might after bishop c4
bishop e6 bishop b3 to my eyes
knight c6 looks a little strange i i
would have thought the knight was better
placed d7 first of all what's the most
popular continuations
knight c6 or knight d7
without the moves h3 h6 if we take these
two moves back so exactly
right we don't have these two moves this
is the variation that's normally played
this is how grandmasters think
we put this mentally on the back burner
and compare it and contrast to
variations that we do know exist and as
you pointed out yasser this has been
reached before the most popular move in
this position is castles knight bd7 is
the second most popular third most
popular all the way down there with only
five games is the move knight c6 now to
be fair the move bishop e6 is not the
most common here here most people castle
before map obviously putting the bishop
on e6 so bishop b3 is a position that's
been reached dozens of times but not the
thousands that we're used to in such an
early night or right perhaps knight c6
is not the most popular but in this
particular night of if is a very logical
move nothing wrong with the move knight
bd7 but this one is a different approach
at some point this knight which is
usually kind of
lame in the night earphone c6 here has
the immediate idea of going to a5 and
maybe hits the bishop directly maybe you
want to take it maybe you just want to
install your knight on c4 either way
it's going to be a really nice knight
because
whereas this maneuver takes a long time
white already spent to tempe with his
own bishop so it gives black the freedom
to maneuver a little bit more let's call
it freely without the constraints that
you must finish development white still
hasn't finished his is not proposing any
pawn breaks so perhaps you have the time
to maneuver all the way to a5 i think at
this point where you develop the knight
is a matter of style
and especially with the pawns
where they are the computers think it's
an even better version for black because
in this particular one we're not talking
a lot of about the king side we're
talking about maneuvers on the queen set
and i think that is why knight c6 was
played by duda
wonderful now i have a question in the
same position um so
from uh in the the game between um naka
and duda so
the i
when it comes to night orifi i really
like to try and um
play things that are not as well known
right off the beaten tracks
although it's hard to get off i know
right
really hard right
so uh the
when you were explaining the the lines
without h7h6
i noticed that knight d5 still existed
but it wasn't like a huge deal but um
here also knight t5 looks interesting
i'm sorry uh in the current position at
the game
okay
so
um i was just trying to understand why
yeah because knight d5 makes us
interesting in the sense that uh
yes exactly and black is kind of tickled
into all right well you better take that
knight and if we put out the one pair of
knights and the light square bishop for
both sides it feels like well this is
you know a classic good bishop bad
bishop type of situation so how is this
any different than without h3h6 i think
in this particular case um i'm kind of
going to challenge you to land on b6 if
you want
you're welcome to trade but then you're
kind of on my terms right you you you
wanted me to take on d5
and i refused that now if you
do
push my queen
i'll go to queen d7 and at this exact
moment i haven't been injured in any way
i still
um
more or less i'm going to ask you to do
something about e4
in other words i don't think the knight
d5 move forces a reaction okay kind of
like what you were saying though if you
did force me to take
um i of course don't want to tape the
knight and get forked by the pawn but if
you did force me to take dorset did you
want to take with a bishop exactly at
this moment so that way you
you you're inviting this type of
situation
where okay now you're happy you've got
your control over the d5
at the end
again the specifics of the position
right right
would be a little scared for black
if i had to play something like castles
and allow rook d1 even long castle
but if i have queen a5 here i feel that
you're just you don't have enough
material to be better as white night
takes takes and then you just kind of
like okay you've got one good square but
okay maybe on a good day i'll have a
safe king and a
yeah i mean i've seen
i
one match that was actually played in
linares ages and ages ago viswanathan
and nan versus vasily yvonne chuck
in fact
vishy had a structure with a pawn on f6
and he got an f5 and he got in another
f5 and
he actually won a beautiful
model game so it's it's not just play on
one goal even if you do
manage to somehow
win the d5 square all by yourself now
having said all of this knight c6
this is
i think
the game that hikaru wanted
a game that's going to be full of
struggle um
you know if duda wins uh tip of the hat
but
icaru's coming into this game feeling
like
he's got a
dare i say it an opportunity of a
lifetime
to become second in the tournament and
then to discover that
magnus might refuse to play
i dare say our streamer would be would
be golden uh he'd get uh he'd get a
ticket to a two million euro match and
this is what i'm talking about we're
expecting that dinglerin will draw
he'll be in the dugout in no time with
seven
hikaru an opportunity to maybe pass
dingler in seven and a half and that
sets up their match
of round 14.
again ding and hikaru will play in round
14. and let's take a look at the fabby
game what's happening in in that one
alejandro i'm trying to figure it out
there's something weird going on in that
game
what take a look at this we got a very
normal catalan with
an early d take c4 bishop g2 this is a
line that's been seen very often
recently this throwing of the check on
b4 now against bishop d2 there's a
couple of ways of playing at it in this
particular moment you don't really go
bishop e7 you play this bishop e7 lines
when the pawn is still on d5 not usually
when you take on c4 so in this position
a lot of things have been said uh a5 is
very common c5 is gaining tons of
popularity at the moment c5 followed by
b5 super aggressive
but
white is on the verge of being better
but still pretty popular line a5 not as
popular and here the move queen c2 is
almost automatic castle's also played
but queen c2 is definitely better
putting immediate pressure on the pawn
on c4 and here after some bit of a thing
castle queen takes c4 was played uh the
move castle is already pretty rare like
extremely rare we have 10 moves played
sorry 10 moves 10 games played from this
position with the move castle
316 with bishop takes the 2 112
knight c6 b5 30 times i've played this
myself with white and i've never thought
of castle because
castle gives up the pawn on c4 for free
usually the way that you play this
variation black is trying to hold on to
the pawn on c4 for as long as possible
and try to get some concession
out of the white side
what am i talking about sometimes you go
with the move b5 and then you have to go
a4 and then we start this battle on the
queen side which is not as crystal clear
as it looks at the beginning eventually
they figured out why this better in this
position stop playing the move b5 but
then through in the move bishop takes d2
first the followed by b5 c5 has been
seen as well as i'd said very recently
30 games with the move c5 castle
extremely rare extremely rare queen
takes e4 i mean it's the only logical
you got to take the pawn and then after
an eight minute thing which is what
fascinates me
fireplay the move b6 played four times
in the history of chess
extremely rare and the question
is obvious
what if i take them on
the training
uh i'm not sure yet uh bishop a6 i guess
you throw this in right right though
that that's a that's a hugely important
tempo i would guess i would guess uh the
queen has to go somewhere i want to win
the pawn so queen b3 it's the only
logical move right right otherwise no
why did you play bishop takes b4 you
have to take this bishop there's nothing
else
i don't see why you don't take the pawn
and i have an engine so i'm going to
take it right and now the question is
where
is
black's compensation there's a line i
have a suspicion knight c6
knight c6 just doesn't work no this is
the problem is you go queen d2 and
where's your break like what is white
what is black's next move i didn't just
give up a pawn i gave up the center
i'm one move away knight c3 or castle
for him i think just fully consolidating
castle comes with rook c1 will be a
tempo this diagonal is a problem you
don't have e5 any time soon and even if
you did it's not that great
so no no comp at all actually white's
saying white has the pawn and the comp
i'm assuming
i'm assuming it's gonna be c5 like this
is a fabio prep i know i know my boy it
has to be c5 okay on queen d2 i assume
then you play knight c6 and you say haha
i got c7 c5 for free and somehow there's
some comp i don't know
i assume this is the way right but the
more selling question right what happens
if i take this
right you can't take back you know you
might see six knights
right intakes you have down three whole
pawns but after queen c8 the engine is
only giving a very slight advantage to
white
so this must be something that we're
going to be looking at
we could die with a full tummy you could
it is three one it is three count them
three once extremely rare that is
extremely rare for now i'm trapping the
queen so you have to retreat and the
game kind of goes on guys i mean this is
going to be a wild gun wild one bishop
takes before bishop a6 already on the
board queen b3 b3 is the only move a
takes before is the only move if you
don't take that pawn then what are you
doing what are you doing with your life
c5 is going to come anyway you have to
take this pawn right right
and he did he did
he ate it and
c5 let's see how much i know mike
right
just for a lot of the fans i remember
one game i think it
was a lokland wellie if you put the
queen back on b3 for a moment
something similar like this white often
times plays a move knight like knight e5
trying to get black to play a move like
c6 but queen takes d4
these exchange sacrifices are almost
automatic oh i remember one of these
exchange sacrifices not the same
position but this idea of taking on the
1425 and giving up that a8 i remember
the game shabbat shankland actually was
shankling shabalov from a u.s
championship here and
it was the early versions of b5 where
white did play knight d5 and took on a8
and shanklin came out fuming from that
game he said ah chapala refuted the
catalyst chabal refuted the catalan
of course a whole new variation was
actually born from those early games on
early b5s but they didn't quite refute
the catalan but still and i know my boy
yeah
there we go there we go
we're gonna go into a mess guys okay
well we are taking it we're taking i
mean there's no choice yeah and i think
after knight c6 it looks like queen d2
and maybe this is the only real question
right
well do you play queen d2 or do you take
on c5 questions i was thinking we take
on c5 knight c6
and then we have a think
because we can play queen d2 in that
position yeah but this i think is the
worst version if you were threading to
castle right maybe but if you allow me
to take on c5 remember now you're not up
three pawns you're not even up two
points you're having one it's not very
much so you do have this blast pawn but
this feels like a benco type
compensation okay where you have the
open b file the open a file and again
what you're able to castle freely i
think you would be very happy with this
right but e2 is hanging right right if
your castle queen takes right here and
you take
rook fe1 the angels actually like this
for white
despite the fact that material is even i
guess they think that this bishop is
very misplaced and knight e5 is coming
so perhaps a thing here for uh timor and
there's no way he knows this very he
should no no
no no he definitely gets surprised but
these guys are strong when they get
surprised they just sit down and think
what's the press practical approach to
this position
exactly i think he says dc knight c6
queen b6 that's way too crazy i expect
queen d2 no matter what the engine says
now because of
fabi and timor's situation that they're
trailing
hikaru and ding by half a point
they want a game where they're both
swinging for the fence they want to
destroy each other
there is no there's no middle ground for
it exactly hikaru plays ding tomorrow if
you think about the world championship
match
and a shot at it right one of these
sides has to win
if they draw they draw each other out of
the tournament exactly
and that's uh so
tomorrow's parents the final round of
the event five is looking at this and
saying fuji is checked out for you just
checked out this is my chance right this
is my chance i gotta beat this guy with
the white pieces i've already done it in
the first half i did it in the grand
swiss i'm white this time
i gotta go for it he might be tired and
farruja well he might be a little
fresher from today's game i don't think
it's going to last that long but it
doesn't matter you have to go for it
now
david bronstein one of the really great
thinkers of chas
explained that white's advantage of the
first move was such that he
white could gambit
but black making a gambit was was a
great risk um your take on this gambit
that
fabio fabi is trying against timor
alejandro is this
too great a risk i mean give me give me
an engine in a couple hours i'll refute
this there's no way i believe in this
right but timor doesn't have
neither two hours or an engine he has to
figure it out on the board this is what
we call a one-time idea right a one-time
idea is something that favi loves to use
he used it in the 2018 world
championship match against magnus
carlsen this rook d8 line of the queen's
gamut decline total bluff if you sit
down
with an engine we actually calculate it
out to a
end game that was really horrible and
you could kind of still hold it
but the path there was so hard and so
complicated that we thought magnus
there's no way magnus is going to sit
down on the board and calculate all of
that out and make sure that he's
actually correct there were so many
pitfalls
in the way and magnus halfway through
his calculation said okay forget about
this let me just go for the easy save
draw and that's exactly what happened in
the game here maybe not not so much
bailout for timur right that's why i'm
thinking maybe he'll play queen d2 which
is more sedate right i'm sure the dc
queen b6 somehow somewhere
uh the engines will figure out is an
edge for white or an advantage for white
but you got to get there first fabio
already got there in his home prep i'm
sure that he analyzed this with chuchel
of yesterday but timor has no clue
what's going on
yeah three pawn sacrifice stores say you
gotta say i mean have you ever prepped
uh in
in your uh openings uh a three-pawn
sacrifice it's very very rare i mean i i
can't speak myself with like exchange
sacrifices here and there but three
pawns and connected pawns
yes it feels a little i mean it's a big
risk i'm not fabulous exactly
he can do whatever he wants but it's
it's definitely
a little out of my comfort zone
but i'm very stingy with my material
good for you good for you i like it
but for me again i'm thinking that you
know you got to play the tournament
situation bobby
was in second first second place for
such a significant number of rounds
before he had
a couple of
losses and uh finds himself in this
situation
actually somewhat fortunate that he's
still in a situation where
arguably you know a 2-0 finish could get
him into the world championship match
that's
that's kind of lucky you know that he's
still he's still in there with a shout
definitely keep an eye an eye out for
this one
i wanted to jump back to our oops that's
not the game i wondered where is um
nepo just that is netball
yeah yeah you found him
damn
sorry i
i was thinking uh
never mind okay this was it this is the
napo game this is the uh
richter rouser knight takes c6
it's very unusual this knight takes c6
but it transposes back right
so there's a line with f3 here knight
takes bishop takes f3 h6
d5 queenie one right yes
not play but kuni one is the line yeah
yeah so between the females that go
between f4 and f3 i mean i've played
them both i'm a bigger fan of f4
personally because
i just see f4 i feel drawn to doing it
exactly but so
maybe you can guys help me out
maybe you guys can
help well i i mean i rely upon
coach yes as you say for my theoretical
uh
astuteness uh f2 f4 coach main line is
still the main line of the variation but
there's nothing wrong with f3 it's a
matter of style and how you want to
attack on the king's side f4 i think is
seen most of the time
but the sharper option i think is f3 i
think to the best of my knowledge so for
a very brief period of time i worked
with rest in peace uh
cuvenus
yeah he was such a wonderful he he
helped me redo all my sicilian when i
was back in iran still and um like i
remember he was like the f4 line there
were like so many things that he was
showing me for like eventually the dream
position is to take on f6 make sure that
pawn takes and then you at some point
you get pawn f5 you bring a bishop to e2
you go bishop to h5 and you just sit
there and you just enjoy your life yes
so just to uh show the viewers again
this is like very long in the future
eventually right
right yeah but
just just to put some moves on the board
for a moment uh let's say b5 as as a
move uh bishop here and let's say rook
c8 so cavanis was teaching you that you
get your bishop on h5 and pressing
against f7 you put your pawn on f5
pressing against e6 and you just sit on
the position happily and
score a much
needed victory if i'm not mistaken it's
been years but i remember not an exact
position but that idea there was a very
nice judith poger game that he made that
she memorized oh that he made it
that she won who was her opponent i
can't recall i just remember you
memorized the moves but not the names of
the players i remember there was a
treated pogba okay that's pretty good
that's a partial thank you thank you
but there were a lot of games there and
it was like i never in my classical
lifetime managed to get that position
that that idea of bishop of h5 f5 i got
it so many times in blitz and rapid but
never ever in classical over the
classical yeah yeah but that so that's
like the main thing i always remembered
from rouser with the f4 line but with
the f3 line definitely well now you're
not obligated to take on f6 anymore so
you can just bring the bishop back and
that's yeah that's another
hitting the pawn on d6 and where do we
stand on this very different
uh theoretical uh line you were
mentioning queenie wanna alejandra it's
what i remember this is kind of old
theory
right i seem to remember john nunn
playing like this too yeah not exactly a
spring chicken
anymore
somebody that plays a lot with black was
salof back in the day yes right um and
his opponents obviously with wide repair
traditionally strong e4 players karpov
played this against half i think more
than once okay uh queenie one i think is
the main move he takes d5 as a move but
if you don't play queen e1 i think
you're not very ambitious in this
particular position
okay and how does the line continue i'll
just ask the engine yeah exactly
most people here play bishop b4 it's
almost an automatic there's no good way
of dealing with e takes d5 otherwise
right um
i guess that makes sense right because
if you play bishop e7 for example just
covering the e file good job you got out
of that bin but you haven't gotten out
of this bin the move bishop c4 before or
after i take on d5 doesn't really matter
your pin rook on the queen so you can't
move it i'm going to take on d5
eventually and force an isolated pawn
which is not a good version for black so
most everybody after queen e1 plays a
move bishop b4 i think it's almost
forced everybody plays a3 right
everybody takes on c3 you gotta take
with the queen otherwise why why you're
doing this and then people just straight
up castle i think
let me see if there's any changes to
that oh sorry here actually most people
play bishop a5
bishop take c3 and castle must be fine
as well the latest wrinkle is to play
bishop a5 seems like it and the line
kind of goes on there's b4 there's e
takes d5 there's a lot of theory that if
i go down these games
they're a bit on the ancient side
i mean you have robert hubner against
valerie salove john nunn versus kramnik
when kramnik was very young in 92.
evancho against lanka i haven't heard
that name in forever right maura visher
versus halif manner these are names
of the 90s early 2000s who's who uh
yeah right uh um against shiroff i
didn't even know they were in the same
generation
yeah equally right um apparently he did
and
what well in 1994 sheriff won that game
with black so tons of games but games of
20 25 years ago it's a variation that
was dust and forgotten making a bit of a
comeback in the candidates wow
this was the game i just did want to
check in on was the alarisa versus
dingler end game because again i
somehow i expected that the game would
have been
drawn by now wow they've been playing
for 45 minutes and h5 takes okay uh
they're really going at it i mean uh
white is actually uh
upon up yeah but not playing for the
advantage is he well
bishops of opposite color but wow i
didn't expect uh
to see a pawn sacrifice i don't
understand why uh
took on the like exchanging the rook
fixing the pawn i mean i see that he did
it to eat the pond but it's good enough
but i mean he's the one who played the
four knights so he's the one who's like
dude i'm happy with the draw can we just
get out of here so
i think he just kind of uh complicated
his life a little bit
just a little bit by uh
by fixing upon its pawn structure and
letting those pawns start
well
i i'll take the other side of that coin
and upon up
uh
yeah i mean i've got you you know you
you still have to prove uh like for
example if i play f2f4 are you going to
take ampassam that way
your pawn structure
i would love that as well you would yes
exactly so you're not going to do that
you're going to you're going to be
running your pawns for all of their
worth right
and
it's going to be a long while for me
to prove
that i actually have anything in the
position but okay i mean
i'd rather play white i think
what about you aleandra i mean i i
understand that black has space but
wouldn't you rather hold the extra pawn
in your hand
i don't know i don't know
that's a lot of space that's a protected
past pawn i think that if anybody ever
plays for a win yeah black is going to
be
in a better position
sacrilege the moment the moment you're
going training you have one plan here
you have the plan to go h3g4 correct
everything else is bogus because if you
play g4 without h3 and you create two
pass pawns but they're not playing i'm
playing h3 and g4 you're right
yeah i just i just think that when you
do that yep and when you start actually
rolling those pawns push them baby i
have so much activity with my bishop my
rook and my potential
passport either on e3 or e4 that i'm
gonna be super happy
i feel it's a double-edged game if you
play for a win
cool well maybe we were uh
too
too hasty
in our declaration of a draw draw's
still a huge favor let's talk
okay let's get around we'll we'll
definitely keep uh that one burning uh
on the slow board i this was the timor
uh he's going for it guys dc he actually
went dc show me right what a what a
teamwork grabbing the bull by the horse
i was i was sure he was going to play
queen d2 just because
it looked like the safer choice right
and in this kind of scenario
it felt that your opponent was so well
prepped in dc
like do you really have to test them
right but you know team we're not afraid
of it yeah
on the board let me give you a little
bit of middle eastern history
just a little bit okay okay
so the name tamor is like a um very like
big fighter it's like those general
names usually like if you name your
childhood taymor you expect him to grow
up being a fighter
so well he's living up to us
a genuine tame yeah it's like a persian
like azeri it's like a very very yeah
it's a very warrior-ish name so i mean
he's trying okay oh he's trying it
definitely is that both players are here
knowing that a draw is just as good as a
loss
they don't care about ten thousand
twelve thousand euro difference between
third and fourth right
this this is
the position is a little too too many
too many pounds
i know but uh we might as well explore
it since we do we're the ones that do
have engines we're the ones that do have
the two hours we're scared of this yeah
queen takes b6 uh queen c8 and now let's
just think about this for a moment
because uh
frankly we're worried right we're scared
that the move rook b8 is going to uh
trap our queen and the instant reaction
is like we should just come
hurtling backwards and
cover up consolidate however there is
something to consider that we also have
a bishop
on this diagonal and we could
potentially move our knight whether we
should or not is a different question
knight d2 what you shouldn't you should
not
knight d2 will either encourage a move
like knight to d5 closing the diagonal
okay but
let's just have some fun uh we're up a
couple of pawns uh queen b3
uh do
the worst rook v8
looks good
i'm sure that i'm sure that five is to
analyze this in depth so we can just go
with it he'll probably play e5 if i had
to guess ah instead of rook b8 yeah
i will yeah oops i thought
that was wonderful
that was not me that was not me i tell
you
your mouse is playing tricks on you it
sure is okay let me just get
uh you think e5 e5 is a little more
pressing
cause with the queen on b3
i have this idea of knight d4 and the
only thing preventing me from doing that
is that knight on f3 right so i'm going
to
give it the boot
yeah rook be it
nice but it feels like you know it's
just kind of encouraging the queen to
join back do stuff so no i like the e5 i
mean would i find it in a real game
that's a different question
okay so
let's ask this alien question you go e5
i'll
oh i like knight d4 now
exactly
because
of c2
if i go to a5 i really am asking for
trouble aren't i a little bit oh um we
do have queen d2 yeah queen d2 is just
so much more human it's so much more
human than queen takes b6 guys true
eventually the engines think that white
might be better in that line but i
wouldn't even trust that engine it's
just such a long variation instantly b
takes c5 replied i mean that's also more
or less forced i think
and we've got your much wanted much
desired uh bengal gambit mega
yeah b takes c5 you got this open file
so i really wish i had a bishop on g7
how many should there was a pawn on d5
okay that's not it no longer this
position we have to analyze this
particular version a couple of ideas
here for white there's a lot of them
that just give up the pawn if you go
castle you encourage black to take the
pawn on e2 and as we analyzed a little
bit earlier the engines were liking
white in that position they thought the
bishop on g2 was very strong this bishop
on e2 may be misplaced if you castle and
cannot take on e2 because the engines
don't think it's the best maybe you just
start with the move queen e7 move the
queen out of the way prepare rook ft8
prepare rook fb8 start harassing the
pawns on the b and a lines is white
better here i'm not so sure i mean black
does have some immediate compensation
rook d8904 coming for example especially
against the move knight t3
so
still a lot of activity here the black
is um
the white is the one that needs to
neutralize right and we're in for a game
in which rod timor the fighter needs to
figure out how to
squash this firing coals because it's
fabiano that's coming after him well
i feel like trading queens although it
might not be the best engine move it
does give white the best um possibility
to get out of the way
no because probably problem with
thinking is that you have to really
answer this pawn on e2 and i think this
is the big thing that you when you
analyze this position you see that this
pressure is not allowing you to castle
of course so this is going to be the
main thing if you play knight c3 to
defend this pawn this way again it's all
about this pawn on e2 if you castle
you're up a pawn and it's already an end
game so i'm going to play knight d5 to
get rid of this bit knight on c3 it's
the only defender of v2 once you castle
if you don't castle you can't bring all
your pieces into the game agreed
compensation for sure is it enough for a
pawn
that will take me a lot
to really answer that question it looks
kind of close
to a pawn to me right but
it's hard to say exactly if it's worth a
full one i don't know yasser your
impression like white i like white i
also like the i also like white's
position after castles
queen takes d2
knight takes d2 bishop takes e2 simply
returning the pawn
and um
asking black well
your
your materials even but
i've got a target i've got a very very
clear target the spawn on c5
my bishop on g2 like many times in a
catalan is is lurking on the diagonal
waiting to try to ambush into
shish kebab
and exchange yeah thank you exactly
something like this so it's it feels
like
yeah white's for choice i i just can't
say by how much i mean just it it feels
like it could be uh
um
evan-ish and of course this game is so
important to fabby as are the hikaru and
big lorraine games
last chance saloon how much do you think
it is a last chance let's say he draws
today right i think he's out
yeah but he draws they say car doesn't
win dinner and let's say it doesn't win
against alera i mean
and then they play each other
what is the favorite result in hikaru
versus thing
let's say draw you're right favi has
white against alareza tomorrow and he's
gonna press it for everything every last
drop exactly exactly that game will not
finish till the ninth hour right that
will be a three-way
or a second
but you know this is like um you know
you're trying to legislate you know uh
outstanding endings and you know first
of all
uh kudos to fidei
to coming to the determination that this
candidates in case there was a tie for
first
play play play playoff
no more mathematical and i like that i
like that very much
how could they have anticipated that
nepo runs away with the tournament so no
worries about a playoff
magnus declines and then you have three
players tying for first and the second
that uses a mathematical tie
i mean you know somebody at feed a are
probably tearing their hair out right
now saying please please you know
somebody wins second clear
so we don't don't even have this
discussion why is this escaping me the
law when something can go wrong yes
it will go wrong uh murphy's murphy's
law that's what it is
i mean you just can't imagine that
second would be
like relevant the whole point of this
tournament is irrelevant winner takes
all one winner seven losers and then we
go home guys
how how could they anticipate this i
know
true
well the last one
the last candidates went for two years
the candidates
we had 2013 where we had this debacle of
the mathematical tie break everybody
running around with the pen both first
place is losing right in the
it's like the candidates brings it guys
it brings in the action this is why we
do commentary on it because we just
never know what's what happens and think
thankfully magnus has made some noise
about this because my god what a boring
tournament this would have been as the
depot is so far ahead it's everybody but
second is important and as you mentioned
it's sodom-born burger that is the first
tie break in this uh tournament
it's currently we already have the
mathematical
for line done yeah so for the moment
ding is ahead of hikaru but that still
might change depending on the results of
other games right then after that it's
head to head although sonoma sunnyborne
burger being tied is rare then it comes
head to head and
at that point like if you're still tied
i have to check but i don't think you're
going to still be tight after that
crazy tournament the chess of it the
um so the tie breaks the the most
painful tiebreak i ever was caught on
was everything everything everything is
absolutely the same the math is the same
and they go by alphabetical order and
the other person i was up against she
had a
as last name a as first name and i'm
like
wait you lost
a dorsa direction
lost an alphabetical tiebreaker
to her opponent who was anna aardvark
she had the double a
in the alphabet
tie break
i mean
i've never heard of the alphabetical
title i heard it and you know why
because unlike most chess players i
actually read the regulations
you know when chess players come to
events and they like have no idea what
the event is like they don't know the
time control they don't know the rest
they don't know the format they don't
know they especially don't know the tie
break right players go into events
having zero idea once i was reading like
seventh tiebreak
yeah i was like coin flipping
coin flip
we haven't we hadn't had the us
championship we had the roulette wheel
uh at the tie break too we've had all
kinds of nonsense i lost the tie break
it was for the third place it wasn't for
the first place for in a world youth
championship to a coin flip and i i i
just it's you lost a literal coin flip
it's you name it i've lost it i've
realized dorsa because we had two of our
longest games the days the two days you
showed up you're bad luck and i'm not
gonna get into the tie break with you
you know
then you sit down and pick nepo get out
of here wow uh okay uh
i'm still i'm still laughing about
about the
alphabetical tie break take it easy over
here
[Music]
where are my team
nice
uh
what's your worst tie break uh you were
talking southern burnt burgers my worst
typing my worst diver kiss when they had
me play an armageddon for the u.s
championship against kamsky
and then i go i started the game with 19
minutes and kamsky started with 45.
i was like what kind of what kind of
system it was some very terrible system
and shout out oh it wasn't terrible it
was great you guys were bidding for
black we're bidding for black but but he
went 20. it was amazing you went 19.
well i went 19 and 45 i knew he was
going to go 20 i had an intuition that
he was going to go 20. so i won it
because i really wanted to play black
okay but
it was just too much of a time
difference but it was the system forces
you to do so you want to win the
tiebreak you want to go super low but
it's just such a huge time advantage
it's insurmountable at that level it
it's more than double the amount of time
and whoever came up with this didn't
really think it through in my opinion we
used it for a couple of championships
and then i think we very rightly got rid
of it oh yeah it's good to experiment
once in a while but man
how can you have an armor yet on a tie
break match when one side starts with
half yeah you start with a few minutes
less
get it but 19 minutes to 45 is just it's
just too much man that that was quite
the challenge that you uh you pulled off
there
i have to ask what was the result of the
game alejandra unfortunately he lost no
no
oh
no oh we drew both yeah and i'm sorry
the armageddon i lost right yeah right
right right yeah he
that i think he won his fifth
championship with that i want to say yes
that was his fifth we're very very very
uh strong opponent by the way do we have
more moves
we have a lot more moves than this one
in the hikaru game i want to take i want
to take this one uh we had this
inclusion of h6h3 and where what are
players coming up with they're coming up
with ways of trying to exploit the moves
nuances little differences in details
and here after bishop c4 bishop e6
knight c6 he car plays a move knight h4
with the pawns on h2 and h5 this doesn't
work let me explain to you why this
tactic would work without the pawns
where they are right now why because
after bishop takes c6 knight takes c3 if
you are compelled to take on c3 in this
position
then your position it's not that good
after bishop takes h4 you could claim
some comp
but you're down a pawn right uh you get
your bishop to d5 again some cop but i'm
not really sure it's enough
instead because the pawn is on h6 check
this out you have the move queen h5
bingo bingo if you go g6
i just take on g6 with the knight
and if you castle which is the best move
in this position there's a cool move
knight g6
saving this knight attacking f8 and you
still have in your pocket this pawn
takes c3 move white ends up on exchange
because you don't want to play rookie 8
run into bishop takes f7 right um
what is up on exchange complex position
white doesn't have a full advantage here
also compensation because of the double
pawns but you see the tactics that
emerge only because this pawn is on h6
things that work things that don't work
not each i'm being told is a novelty and
an interesting one so duda wants nothing
to do with these variations instead
finally
ask the bishop are you going to take on
e6 if you don't take on e6 right now i
will take with the knight and now this
move knight h4 looks super awkward
you gotta follow through bishop takes
pawn takes and again because the pawn is
on h6 and no no not on h7 this knight
gets a new idea this pawns like this
this knight is ridiculous on h4 exactly
but it's not ridiculous because they can
now hop to the knight on g6 have to move
the rook out of the defender somewhere
recon h7 is just terrible so you move it
to g8 and we have the move castle on the
board fascinating struggle now because
this king it doesn't have a lot of
places to go to do you want to castle
queen side
question you could do it you could it is
possible to do it later on the game but
it's going to take you a while and you
already have the open c file on the
other hand the king doesn't is not
forced to go anywhere anytime soon for
the time being the king is safe queen h5
is not possible the moment you play f4 i
will more seriously consider castling
queen side because now you've given
yourself an isolated pawn in the center
these pawns great job defending the
central positions that being said white
does have an annoying knight on g6
that's not easy to get rid of you don't
want to get rid of it with king f7 you
could play king f7 right now force me to
take on e7 but then the king stuck there
and i will try to hunt you down with f4
don't necessarily want to put the king
on f7 even though it's a possibility so
fascinating struggle right now between
both sides uh the angels prefer why the
smidge but i think it's pretty relevant
it's a full-blown double-sided
double-edged affair not super tactical
for the moment we're going to have a
couple more developers in the position
knight c4 kind of screams to be played
so i expected uh quite soon
uh but other options also good queen c7
preparing long castle this move king f7
can't be underestimated i think at some
point you might want to look at it so
tons to consider for both sides clearly
out of theory for both this is the type
of knighters that hikaru certainly
wanted to see something in which the
position is unclear it's unbalanced and
he feels he can outplay a weakened duda
exactly wonderful and by the way i was
just going to say that in the game of
between jan and richard
very very slowly
both players
are getting into the theoretical
positions that
alejandro was discussing
i i i was under your depression yeah
bishop b4 as aleandro was mentioning
this seems to be by far the most popular
move
a2 a3 again the most popular answer
apparently both
bishop a5 as well as bishop c3
and he went through a who's who of the
1990s players
apparently bishop a5 might be a more
modern approach but bishop takes c3 was
chosen very quickly nepo recaptured
queen takes c3 castles
and we've caught up with the players
whose clock times
seem to be about 30 minutes each more or
less yeah you're correct the nepal has
um
an hour 30 and rapworth has an hour 24
so very very close yeah but again slow
slow play uh by uh both players
dinglerin that was the bishops of
opposite colors did your f4 f4
slowly slowly and fabi um
no uh queen takes d8 he chose dorsa he
uh timor that is to say chose your move
queen d takes d8 over
my suggestion of castles and just go
ahead give back the pawn right away on
e2 and go after the c5 pawn he timor
took on d8 knight c3 95
rook c1
knight takes c3 we've caught up with the
players where
i'm assuming there was a novelty
somewhere
in there
yeah kind of technically the move brooks
knight d5 uh rook a b it had been seen
in some correspondence games
including a correspondence games of 1982
wow sorry says that again at which
moment
oh sorry elliot go ahead yeah instead of
the move knight d5 right here which is
what the engines were recommending rook
ab8 had been seen in what i think are
two correspondence games because i don't
recognize uh either of any of these four
players
um but one of them is from 1982 i have
to check this game out because 1982
there were no engines around at least
they were not very good
if you're not familiar with
correspondence chess and why i'm
equating it with engines it is accepted
to use engines in correspondence chess
it's not cheating
it's encouraged you're supposed to be
using engines it's completely allowed
it's an open book type of game so
engines have been completely taking over
opening faces
knight d5 is the novelty let's call it
that way roxy one took five a little bit
by surprise and i think we are in danger
maybe with teamwork in danger somebody's
in danger of drawing themselves out of
this event because knight c3 is already
on the board pawn takes c3 is just no
good right you go rook aba rook b2 even
bishop c4 you just capture this pawn
that's terrible so quickly yeah you
don't get time to do any of this so it
takes c3 you have to take with the rook
right i think it's just box you don't
want to defend this with black you could
throw in the move c4 but unfortunately
you realize that the pawn is on the way
of the bishop so white can just castle
you're not getting your full comp
because knight somewhere will be a tempo
against this knight on c6 okay so
you play rook ab8
you hit that pawn great simple tactics
if you take on c5
i take on b2 that's not good if you
defend right i go knight before
and again
i'll pick that up is that a big deal
yeah yeah no maybe i mean you could take
on c5 i'll take here
and at this point you can start to see
where the draw is right right somehow
i'll defend this pawn yeah i don't even
need to really i can even castle
and after bishop takes e2 or rook takes
b3 we will probably get some structure
like this
four on four maybe three on four in some
occasions but with an awkward knight on
a2
straight
into
a
draw we do have a few extra moves as
well
rook c3 played same game same game rook
takes c3 well yeah rook c3 would
definitely expect and we expect rook ap8
is the only logical move
i can see in this position because c4
doesn't work straight up yep you you
have it on the board yeah rook ab8
and you can take on c5 and i can take on
b2 we can go through these variations a
little bit you take on c6 well thank you
for not knowing how chess works rugby
one is checkmate you probably will
castle it's the only move
and then more than one way to skin this
cut if you want to make a draw since
these pawns are hanging you could play
knight d4
it looks that scary that there's a back
rank
but nothing to worry about says the
engines for example the move like route
k5 yeah this looks a bit awkward i get
it but you'll play g6 you'll play king
g7 one of these pawns will drop just not
enough activity for the right side other
way of doing this is instead of
calculating knight d4 you just take on
e2 just lazy grandmaster
because takes takes takes
takes yeah two pieces against the rook
but you still have your pawn
play on one side i mean this is like
ultra drawn i would be not i would not
be afraid of this as black whatsoever
i don't know about you yasser
no no this is pretty this is pretty
clear right so i think this is one of
the variations that we're going to go
down either b3 knight before or rook
takes c5 rugby two and they both seem so
clearly drawn to me
that
well
that that's it yeah i mean we're gonna
have to wait for five versus ferocious
tomorrow and i'm sure hikaru and dingle
are both looking uh this game over sorry
but i i need to ask you uh alejandro
about our tournament leaders game
because
they're going right down the fairway i
like to say
uh
of uh theory the fairway let's put it
the highway the highway the highway was
bishop a5 and they're taking a side exit
oh okay this bishop takes c3 move is
actually pretty rare most of the games
that i have here
are again names i don't recognize so i
have to fill in their correspondence
games as well
uh bishop takes c3
it's just better according to the
engines than this move
modern engines have killed a lot of
lines from the 80s 90s even early 2000s
this might be one of them because they
just say take take and b4 and if this
type of stuff works which was not
considered back in the day i mean even
back in the day they took on f4 and they
played for the compensation but i think
nowadays the engines know how to play
with the queen so strongly
that this might not be full comp sure a
complicated complicated game
but it kind of goes on castles instead
retains material parity but white does
have the pair of bishops most people
here or most engines i guess have played
the move bishop p5 a very logical move
you put pressure on f6 you don't allow
the knight to move easily 97 is not
possible because bishop takes g7 but
then again black has their own threats
rook c8 for example challenges you
bishop takes f6 leads to a nothing end
game bishop a4 is a threat because of
the discovery of the rook on the queen
and on c2
black has their own chances and i think
this is what richard is looking forward
to
not a lot of games position remains in
my opinion balanced and everything to
play for on both sides typical style
very fun sicilian
well thank you alejandro well very
interesting around 13.
shaping up as we get ready to take a
break i see that you've got something
from cute boutique that you'd like to
tell our viewers about
so
everybody knows how much i love my
chess appeal right absolutely so this is
one of the beautiful colors i really
enjoyed this one
with jean that would look wonderful
so this is one of the tournaments
emerges it's from last year's
sinkhole cup polo a sinkhole cup
polo there we go and it's very it's very
nice very light blue um it's uh it's
kind of a but i want to say athletic
appeal but it's also i have it so i know
it's very very lightweight um it has
official logos
it is available in both men and women's
styles
and um
this seems like a woman's style actually
yes it does
yeah i like that thank you yeah
so it's a very pretty one and you can
shop for it at q boutique st louis dot
com
look for the coupon discounts just say
yes
three percent tops top stops we'll see
you on the other side of this break but
before we go to break i just want to
tell you what you can expect on the
break we had gary kasparov on the show
two days three days ago gosh
i know but yeah it wasn't the rest day
uh and gary had some really in
as he usually does fantastic insights on
the future world chess championship have
a listen
[Music]
uh gary we want to thank you very much
for having joined us but i also
do want you to get in a last word if you
don't mind
we consider nepo's victory as just
assured
should
he play
a rematch with magnus should magnus
accept
and play the match
your thoughts about a second
nepo versus magnus
match will it be a better match
look um
i still think madness is a clear
favorite in the match but
i think somehow neville might have a
better
psychological um
start
because he already played magnus and
magnus will be
definitely i mean we know magnus is
not tired but it's
i think he's bored too many matches and
seeing napo again might
lower his
enthusiasm for preparation and for
playing um
so if history
is any he is offering us any guidance
so magnus played two matches with vichy
but again that's that was the beginning
of magnus reign
and
he
he was you know it's much fresher and he
still believe you have to prove that he
is the best but do you remember the
second match you know it's a again game
six this is magical
he was you know he was one move away
from losing and that could be a very
different match exactly so um
and also by the way let's not forget you
know if we look at history but silva
smith was the only one who won two
candidates in the row in 53 and 56
and after winning the second second
match he beat but winnick in his 95th is
a world championship match again it's an
ancient history but still
so winning second man second candidate
especially in this style that that we
saw in madrid so definitely makes
networks in my view a very formal
opponent for magnus no matter you know
what magnus thinks about it and uh and
if magnus plays and i
i can hardly believe he will not so um
then we'll see probably a tougher match
and
and it seems that napo is is getting
more um
resilient so it's the
is
more stable
and um and i guess this match probably
taught him you know some very important
lessons
uh yes some say oh he was lucky here he
was lucky with hikaru he was like it was
karana he was lucky maybe it was ding in
the first round who could have thought
that would be such an important game
round one of the tournament
uh but
you know it's yes if you're so lucky
that means you know you are you are
really a winner so because this this
only winner can accumulate so much luck
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
here we are in round 13 as
nepo with this two-point lead yeah
nobody's catching him but it's all about
the fight for second as
these four players are right in a
thick of things real slugfest going on
uh of all of them i don't like ding
lauren's position at the moment i think
if anything
he'll be lucky to scrape to a draw today
but hikaru's game is full of
vim and vigor versa uh three results
possible there and uh let's just jump
quickly to our
uh tournament leader i always like to
give the player whose first
respects of course okay
and
we're actually as it turns out in a
position
which is very theoretical the the
players have not left theory uh the last
move bishop f4 to e5
by yon is considered the best move and
um
white is considered to have the
advantage thanks to his two bishops but
the players have played it very slowly
dorsa to get here what's
how much time has been taken by both
it's quite interesting they both have an
hour 16.
both on an hour and 16. so they've taken
44 minutes each
to get to a position that's actually
well established and well known and
indeed uh
before we went on a break rook c8 was
the move that was prescribed by
alejandro that move sets up the threat
of bishop a4 a discovery against the
queen and by the way there's a pawn on
c2
uh that's uh pretty tender oh they're
playing quite fast that was an instant
reaction bishop takes f6
and uh they're still following the uh
precepts of theory as seven games with
bishop takes f6 or in our database now
pressure of sex is quite interesting oh
and coincides obviously um i'm assuming
white is going to just trade everything
off and right so
considering the tournament situation
that's nepal just needs a draw to just
go home pop the champagne for the 50.
that clinches
first place that's exactly right all he
needs is a draw and mathematically
nobody
can catch him so he was very happy
to make those trades on f6 and i assume
he's going to
take and you've got to take with the
bishop taking where the pawn will be a
disaster
then you play bishop to d3 and
pretty much you can pre-move your next
two moves you're gonna go rookie one
bishop e4 trade more pieces and get into
a dead
dead drawn a rook upon ending so for
nepo this has been
the type of tournament when you look
back on it you go
wow
that went right that went right that
went right that went right there i mean
it's just been an amazingly remarkable
tournament where everything is going
right for him and that's why he's in
first place now having said that let's
jump to the game of ding loren this was
another thing i wanted to mention
because what you said you know like
thing is we'd be lucky to have a draw
and i feel like it will most likely be a
draw just didn't have to
not give up any other puns
but
i think that's this is what happens when
you play four nights i've personally had
so many four nights that you know upon
this higher rate that i'm just going in
and i'm like you know what here's a four
night which you want to do and if they
try to fight it and they don't you know
go to the usual routes that ends in a
pretty easy draw
yeah
this is one of them this is what happens
why does she like a question oh this is
from our uh youtube yeah or youtube but
yeah question for dorso why does she
like the fortnite scotch and it's
because it's a drawish line is it
because you're playing higher rated
players so often most of the time yeah
so like when i was you know when i'm in
the hunt for norms when i was in the
hunt for an arms there are like certain
times that you need a draw to secure the
norm and i messed that up so many times
before so i started to actually grow it
a drawer shoperator i'm like you know
what this is my dryer repertoire this is
what i'll do against french this is what
i'll do against e5 this is what i'll do
against sicilian i want this george
aperture so the next time i'm in this
situation and i need half a point to
secure a norm
i'm good to go
and uh i i did that multiple times and
then i started playing you know more
higher rated events and i'm playing like
2600 26.50 almost 2700 then i'm like
i don't think i can win this guy so i'm
just i think i just want to go for a
nice four night and you know it's the
draw a very beautiful game against the
2650 and just you know have a nice day
tigran petrossian
there's nothing sorry in my opinion
because people keep asking like well
they they there's they have like a
draw is not a win you should always
fight for a win and everything and i
agree with that you should have that you
know fighting spirit but
sometimes it's just
that's not logical to do it's not it's
not about getting that full point it's
not about uh giving it all it's about
you give it all and a draw is completely
fine that's something that you're also
seeing in this tournament a lot of the
players are giving it all
especially for example in the young
richard position the richard gave its
very good fight he didn't just you know
go play the e5 and make a draw but it's
still it still seems to be heading to a
draw so
this there's i just want everyone to
know there's nothing wrong with a drop
not that you should go and just start
offering draws 50 times in a game but
anyways here we go uh tiernan petrosian
famously said that uh he knew he'd
become a good player when players
started as white oh yes making draws
against trying to force
him into making a draw this is the
opposite color uh bishop position six
white pawns five black pawns i'm making
anticipating that after g4
uh dingler and intends to play bishop h4
and just kind of sit with his bishop
there
it does invite chief g5 where your
bishop might be considered offsides
but it's not in the first place it sits
in front of a past pawn and second
nobody's going to be able to kick it out
and
it patrols these three squares so should
it ever need to return into the game
um it stands ready to do that i would
assume that g4
uh bishop h4 g5 would be about even
uh so
maybe ali reza is going to play king h2
and just kind of wait for developments
wait for what though i don't know if you
don't play g4 what's white's plan
exactly uh i thought you were black's
plan what oops excuse me uh what is
black's plant king
c3
and that would be fun
king c5
i mean go all the way to c3 right yeah
uh okay so let's say
it this isn't
i'm not exactly sure what my
my best setup okay let me just go king
d6 king d6 and let's say i go
c h4
king c5
yeah yeah of course why not right
king
let's go king i'll go to d4 just so that
you're actually afraid of the things i'm
doing
i'm afraid
be afraid be very very afraid
yeah i'm not you i don't get my tempo
you're not going to give me king e3 with
a tempo sure if you like thank you very
much okay
and now we think and now we've
uh don't think too long
really because i'll play can i get away
with bishop d6
okay either way i'm gonna get my my two
pawns right it's fine
okay so
um
i don't know i i
don't think it's three results i still
think it's two results but i think draw
is by far it's such an overwhelming
favorite yeah his own overwhelming
favorite but
i have to admit as a four knights
lover i don't like that king on e3 can
we just play g4 bishop h4 g5 and just
get out of here but we're like we're
trying you can always draw you can
always you can always no question yeah
but if i if i
just feels very unnatural to get to
allow that king to come all the way to
e3 and just
well i mean you're trying to win dorsa i
know it's a
they have to happen if i wanted to win i
wouldn't play fortnite
okay trust me you can make a draw
anytime you want we're trying to win i
believe you we're pawn on
we're upon up we're trying
um
is
timor
versus fabby actually strangely enough i
think we actually got to this position
and again alejandro was pointing out
that we could take on c5 but there was
problems with knight takes
well i think we actually
ended up doing this didn't we did he do
this in a different move order it was
something like rook takes c5
knight takes a2 and i think alejandro
was trying the move knight d2
and not getting anywhere i might add but
we we have a different move order
actually we have knight d2 first
it's kind of strange
um
i think that this is
this is a game
unfortunately where both players are
going to draw themselves out of
contention for second
this game
both players needing desperately a win
they're going to uh yeah it's not going
anywhere
yeah yeah
uh so that one looks like it's uh
i mean favi did lay a nice trap with the
queen c8 ideas but it's just i mean if
if teamwork doesn't want to suicide this
is just the draw so
yeah this was unfortunately this was the
moment that you were saying the
queensland yes no not at all this is
where we were thinking that well
it's a three-pawn sacrifice but my
goodness what uh
what dynamic play uh threats
that uh
that uh black has and again uh we're
running out of road here guys there's
only two rounds left and this today is
the penultimate round of fobby and timor
right there in the middle
of the pack tied for four
with six points a piece
looking up at two guys who are half a
point ahead of them and these are
tomorrow's games teamwork black against
richard doesn't get any easier does it
and uh for actually bobby farouzha
fabian first
[Laughter]
you know fair-weathered friends right
you know
louis said louisiana i'm fabi fan okay
i have to you're forgiven it's okay
it's okay you're forgiven let's quickly
jump to
because it happened fast so many things
nepal took
and he he followed up with a much
superior move to what i suggested i had
suggested that
you want to challenge this bishop
uh bishop to d3
rook e1 and bishop e4 that way you could
open the d file as soon as the bishops
are traded
your open d file makes you happy but
nepo played a very nice move i like this
move a lot he played the move rook to d4
so similar ideas but in this case he can
play bishop to d3
rook to d1 and bishop e4 much better i'm
thinking because these are kind of a
i've had a few fortnite experiences with
these can you go before f5 thank you
rook d4 beautiful so what i'm thinking
is if that bishop does get to d3 let's
say just black plays b5 or something yes
a very typical sicilian movie yeah so i
think yeah uh you can the idea could be
that you can just perpetual rock g4
rookies or rook g4 or rick h4 ah you
don't even need they allow and make a
draw this way rook g for rook h4 it was
kind of a fortnight's idea
[Laughter]
no disagreement for me i mean
it sure feels to me like white's playing
for a win also one thing to mention
whenever you do have these
bishops of the same colors i'm not a big
fan of this move f5 but that's a
different matter but i wouldn't be a
really big fan of the move b5 either the
reason is you're kind of putting the
pawns on light squares and maybe you're
encouraging white to play the move a41
suddenly and just like that you know
there's a target in any case uh not b5
pardon me f5 was played bishop and now
we do have a threat
bishop takes
and i think the bishop dropped back
bishop c6 to avoid
that and what you're saying about maybe
getting in uh some checks on the g
file and the
uh
h file would be salient
if you were going to be playing for g4 i
was thinking that he might play
the move rook f1 with the idea g4 or
rock g1
rook g1 i think in either case uh
black's intent is to get out of those
perpetual checks and
maybe scamper towards the
center a lot of king of the hills
king of the hills that's another chess
variant that uh it's very popular around
here too by the way it's kind of hard
for me to win that recently i usually
get queen of the hill faster and then
i'm just stuck okay how do i get the
king to the center why would i want to
get the king to the center you're
talking about a chess variant where you
put your king in the center of the board
called king of the hill and when you are
able to do that
it's like checkmate you win the game
rook to d1 i like white
yeah i prefer the pawn structure i like
the fact that white already has control
over the open d file
okay on a good day somehow i will try to
figure out how to make a majority
c4 king c2 king c3 some something it's
not that easy yet for black to use his
majority but once again alejandra it
just feels to me like uh
uh
the results i'm seeing are
draw is the favorites yeah draw has to
be favored in this end game as well that
you have uh yasser let's not change from
it i agree with you king g7 king f6 is
very likely to come on the board right
even a position where you trade all the
rooks
drop seems to be a huge favorite so you
kind of have to keep two rocks on the
board for white in order to put some
pressure which i think is why rook fd8
might not be the correct move here you
don't trade all the rooks you go bishop
e2 immediately
and then you might have some issues but
kg7 more or less place itself draw a
favorite in that one draw a favorite in
the fabiano game draw a huge favorite in
the dingley writing game i don't care
how many extra pawns you have yeah
you put your faith into these opposite
swords definitely i think the opposite
color bishop end game is something that
dingleran has looked at and he knows
he's not only just playing for a draw
there's no actual danger
for him i have that the feeling that's
true the only game that's chaotic and
wild and cool is this one hikarna
saying i won my second place in this
tournament he's going for it we have
this crazy night of king on f7 actually
finally got there might even castle uh
by hand at some point go to the g8
square knight d1 just played by hikaru
best move by the engine kind of a weird
position the knight is not so much
headed anywhere as it is just vacating
the position on c3 so that b3 is
playable what am i talking about if you
expel my knight from c4 immediately with
the move b3 well check it out knight e3
other moves work as well but 93 or
anything else i'm going to take on c3
there's nothing you can do about it
because you have to defend knight takes
c2 so a move even as natural bishop
takes e3 you should take with the pawn
but even a move as natural as bishop
takes e3 rook takes d3 already lands you
in trouble this is targeted this is a
pin uncomfortable to make any pressure
yeah you got a nice knight on g6 it's
anchored but is it actually attacking
anything it's just annoying it's not
really that threatening so for that
reason the knight retreats first so that
i can play the moves b3 maybe even
follow it up with c4
duda has to be careful that a bind
doesn't completely kill his activity if
you see a good day for hikaru b3 c4
knight e3 bishop a3 all of these moves
that start binding you that don't allow
you to play d5 that force you to defend
this bishop on e7 because it defends d6
you can see the potential in white's
position what does white have to do in
what does black have to do in the
meanwhile he needs to develop some sort
of initiative the engines are thinking
you know
pieces on the back rank right it's time
it's time to go to d5
not the only move but a fascinating move
in this position looks illogical at
first because knight takes e5 is hanging
in some positions but the knight is
covering and the queen is covering on c7
no immediate danger there and if you
take take which the engines are
recommending now you have to reckon with
ideas of e4 you have to reckon with
ideas of this knight going to d6 and e4
itself not possible for the moment
because knight takes e5 but i mean in
the future so a lot of possibilities
here for both sides of the board yeah it
seems a little loose
on the queen side special with the king
on f7 and in the center but again
white is stuck in the back rank for the
moment so you can't immediately put
pressure a move like 93 returning
already e4 rook d8 says advantage black
so a fascinating struggle d5 is possible
it's the top engine move besides rook e8
which is also a logical move so you can
go king g8 and safeguard that king
before anything bad happens
cool game of the night earth here
between hikaru nakamura and shisht of
duda i don't have a full preference on
who i'd rather be the engines are giving
a slight smidge to white but nothing
serious
a great game i just want to hold it
right there because that move d65
man uh
okay so a couple of things go through my
head when i'm making that kind of move
for black i i think
who's better developed and i pat myself
on the shoulders because i think black
has better development so i think okay
therefore with all your pieces
on the first row i'm justified in making
this break i play the move d65 the
second thing that goes through my mind
is whose king is safer when i open up
the board
there's the hesitation
because i'm looking at that king on f7
i'm going okay well just a second just a
second it takes takes b3
and we pause because we do have this
move e4 to consider
and if you know you if you just kind of
start going through
a permutation like knight d6 h5 for me
the e5 is hanging sorry
yes exactly
uh that uh
that was the point my apology yeah no
it's
good okay you i mean well done that was
also what i wanted to say so you're
probably going to have to play e4 but
now
e4 advancing getting space that's all
very good but also you start to think
this knight on g6 a moment ago it was
nettlesome now it's getting scary
because the bishop comes to f4 and
there's a potential fork sorry dorsey i
want to swing at 5 instead of queen h3
just because i i still want my nice e5
okay yeah uh here
knight
e5 check is uh what you got right i'm
still still holding um
wow uh okay c2 is hanging this is
this is a mess a mess it's chaos
but i i do think that uh the move d6 d5
it's one of those breaks where you do it
because you're better developed
but you don't do it because your king is
potentially the more exposed i'm seeing
this is
and by the way we have on the board the
move knight b6 a kind of delaying
such a break and by the way with the
move knight b6 you do hit c2
one of the things that
exactly alejandro
was pointing out there was a positions
where i get to go knight
e3
to g4 and then i start thinking about
bishop takes h6 i'm putting bad move on
board
excuse me i'm putting a bad move on the
board bishop
a5 knight g4 rook c2 just to point out
the kinds of things
that
yeah
you're just going to have to keep an eye
over this knight
uh also hitting this e7 uh
bishop uh
this is
alejandro as they say this is where the
action is that's where the action is
what we like to see knight b6 knight e3
i expect on the board pretty quickly i
don't find a lot of logic with the move
c3 and i don't think you actually want
to give up the pawn so now
93 i think is more or less four so where
is this knight going is the question
right why did i put it on b6 as opposed
to anywhere else i think it's to
challenge this guy i think
97 looks like a logical move to me
because the knight has two routes and
here this is a very personal very
stylistic decision do you want to
reroute this knight to c5 to attack e4
right or do you want to route it to f8
challenge
this guy on g6 i think this is where you
know players think differently right
i don't think there's a right option in
some places there's a right option and a
wrong option in chess and in some places
there are just multiple options and i
think 97 has both ideas on tap it would
be up to him to do that that is on how
he feels like playing today i don't see
another move that's not knight e3 i
think 93 is going to be played almost
automatically i guess
and then after knight d7 yes
i can imagine what you're saying it's
easy to see that black's leaving himself
with two options knight c5 knight f8
white's pieces are still on the first
row uh
gi give me a sense of where you think
hikaru
uh should be putting his
i think it's gonna be meroxy style you
go c4 just to get rid of this pressure
okay you're going to go b3 at some point
how am i meeting knight c5 in that case
knight c5 uh you encouraged me to
whoa to take and you're a bit a bit
stuck this is actually typical of
certain sicilians where these knights
don't move right you might be in a
little bit of trouble and since you
can't get rid of this knight it's not so
easy for you to just deal with moves
like rookie one sometimes knight g4 will
be on tap once they defend that guy the
engine is already giving a very strong
advantage to white wow the the typical
ideas are going to be c5
and the fact that you open up my rook to
the e5 square
so even if i just blunder a pawn away
like let's put a bad move on the board i
don't know
a3 i don't care a a5 let's say a5 yeah
uh well particularly a5 does attack this
bottom b4 but you can imagine that if i
play c5 and you don't have pawn takes
right right imagine that imagine that
you have to take this pawn yes
and now i deal yeah v5 works i don't
care about that the main point is that
you go something like knight g4
and then you attack e5 you attack rook
takes e4 and you start regretting your
structural choices
so i think
that this bonds in the center
they can be taken but they require a lot
of care
after 93 97 c4 i think it's much safer
to go knight f8 okay but knight c5 is
certainly a possibility the thing is you
might get stuck with your hand in the
cookie jar after this knight takes on e4
because this particular pawn is in the
way of a lot of pieces for the attack
it's a valuable pawn it's a great pawn
it's an important pawn but there will be
some scenarios where i do prefer to play
without it just so that the rook can
participate in the attack and those
scenarios are the ones where i can
attack attack this pawn to attack this
pawn i have to attack the bass and
that's why b4 is useful right
you're making a very compelling case for
knight f8 and getting rid of this
knight on g6 which is more than
bothersome that that that night you want
to get rid of so in case of knight of
eight night f8 then hikaru has to sigh
and hem and ha and uh what has he got to
do he's got to trade it off right not a
lot of choices you could try to be
tricky with queen h3 because takes takes
e6 is saying e6 is hanging but i'll just
force your next move i'll play queen d7
defend the pawn right and you still have
the same option nothing really has
changed gotcha uh in both cases the
engine does prefer to take the bishop
over the
the knight over the knight f8 yeah so
that you go takes and they still want to
play b4 c5 actually takes with the queen
i don't know why on earth they took with
the king
you take with the queen b4 c5 is still
on top for white it's still going to be
an idea to target the double pawns on
the e file but in this case my knight is
going to be solidly defending against
that i can play something like b4 net
government b4 knight eight to d7 right
actually just 97 spin knight d7 and this
pawn is currently defended c5 is not
going to come as strongly and it still
challenges white to fight for an
advantage yeah you have some pressure on
d6 but it's not the biggest deal the
knight is a bit stuck defending the pawn
on c4 right but if you play it
quietly with b3 you just don't get as
much space so this knight actually has a
c5 square on tap for himself
b4 a little bit more ambitious b3 less
ambitious but you can kind of see the
structure in which this game i think is
headed 93 on the board i expect knight
d7 allowing c4 but there are other moves
in the position you could start in my
opinion another logical move move this
rook somewhere useful i don't like c8
the reason i don't like c8 is that i
foresee the spawn coming to c4 anyway
you might get jammed up on the c file
exactly somehow i like the potential of
the rook on e8 it's a very sicilian move
it also allows me to take with the rook
on e7 in some cases that will defend the
pawn e6 which is a weakness and i don't
want to tether my queen i would rather
tether a piece that is worthless in this
case a rook that's not doing anything on
g8 i like the move rookie the engines
like rookie knight d7 i think it's a
very human move as well we're going to
have to wait and see 97 already played
by duda so not the engine move but i did
think it was the most logical move from
a human perspective i like it and also
to boot the knight one thing i must say
about these sicilians and
the dairy very dangerous for the first
player these pawns on d6 e6 and
e5
while these pawns are doubled on the
e-file
they cover a lot of squares this knight
unfortunately is rather stuck if it's
not going to g4
um it can't go forwards to f5
and d6 and eventually
more pieces that get traded
the open c file is going to be a very
nice
strategic advantage for black to have so
i like this move knight d7 i like
getting rid of this good night even if
it even if we're forced to get rid of
this bishop but what i'm saying is i
feel as white
then i'm under pressure
to do something before you neutralize me
completely whether it be with rookie
eight
and if you neutralize me completely i'm
afraid that i could actually start to be
worse that the pawns on h5 and e4 could
be potential targets so that's why i
when when alejandro was making
his explanation
uh that's why i would probably
be in the b4 camp that is to say okay
i'm worried about being neutralized i've
got to be aggressive c4 was played in
the game also just played actually yeah
i and and i start to think
that with the move b4 it allows me to
play whether it be a4 b5 or just b5 and
bishop a3 but i feel that i have to
uh i i can't just be circumspect and
slowly slowly it that's not gonna work i
have to be very
brutal now c4 on the board and we'll see
if rookie eight or knight f8 comes
alejandro um other games caught your eye
no no
i mean there's about the three draws
they're all headed there right dingley
rand already has a bishop on h4 the
engines are throwing out triple zero def
45 you can't do anything as either side
right i just want to point out one thing
look at that
time he spent 25 minutes thinking about
g4
25 that's a long time yes i mean this
game is not going anywhere it doesn't
matter how long i'm aware but
this game's not going anywhere i mean
white is underdeveloped right so by the
time you turn the pawn yeah by the time
you finish your development you will
somehow magically have lost b3 you'll
see this happen soon
and when that happens
it's four versus four
yay end of the end of the game this one
is prayer probably the most interesting
out of the three because it's still an
end game with possibilities for both
sides
the structures are different e5 e4 might
come at some point
it's kind of even i would say this is an
equal end game i wouldn't say this is a
drawn end game like if i play this
against a lower rated player in an open
tournament expect to win either side i'm
going to the coffee shop i'm like okay
time for the coffee time for some snacks
because this one's going to go the
distance doesn't matter if i'm water
black we're going to try to win this one
at this level of chess and considering
the tournament situation
maybe not a big as big of a try but
still the players need to prove it
they're still far away from mu 40 where
they can finally offer a draw to each
other and
i think it's just a game
this one is not a draw the way the other
ones i think are a draw that being said
these guys are magicians at finding
three-fold repetitions
magicians
let's see if they find one here
orchestra was just h4 on the board as
you were speaking uh hitting the pawn on
h6 alejandra i want to return to
something that you mentioned at the top
of the show yes you mentioned at the top
of the show yesterday was a rest day for
the players yes
and it just so happened that magnus
carlson was in town how sweet it is and
he played in the blitz tournament in the
park
against judith pogar no the blitz there
was a blitz tournament and he played
some casual blitz against some top-level
players a certain judith polygard came
to the park she's doing the commentary
for the chess 24 team shout out to them
because they do awesome things a lot of
them are over there in madrid and she's
doing the commentary i believe with
anish giri
and this has been a spectacular little
little bit of blitz because julia just
clobbered magnus happens once in a while
she's pretty good at chess she's so good
at chess what an inspiration she's
always been as an attacking player and
she pulled no punches yesterday magnus
did play the blitz sermon but they
didn't win that one either oh my
goodness well that's right but
doesn't that recall the fact that
earlier uh when ali reza went on tilt
and played 250 bullet games with donya
nardiski daniel noradiski
who is also official commentator and
donya won
yes
so the commentators are taking down the
players
the champions
that's pretty awkward for us
commentators i mean you know i think the
most awkward feeling exposed over here
the most awkward for us was when we were
partners in buckhouse
there were three teams us
mvl and levon ironian right and then the
strongest team
magnus magnus and fabiano yeah man they
couldn't win a game
at some point we felt kind of bad
because that was a little bit
embarrassing i just like
i was trying to offer them you know some
candy something you know to to make them
feel better
i mean we were playing
loser gets out right so when you lost a
game
you're out of the board we only have one
board to play with
man
i was sits flash i mean
you know oh my back was hurting that i
didn't get out of that chair for ages
midnight it's time i love you guys trash
talk
amazing but well fortunately they're not
here to defend themselves see for me
like it's the first time i've been
coming through we do like i've watched
you for years and i've loved hearing you
and everything but it's the first time
that we're actually thinking about a
position and talking about it for
such a long time right and so like every
time you're like yeah i want to put my
king there i want to put my piece there
you see it in like five seconds and then
these guys are taking like 20 minutes
right right so for me i would love to
see you just take on these guys one
one by one
funny that you should say one by one by
one there was
it was lovely i was playing in
montpelier it was the candidates
so it's the opening ceremony we're all
on stage spasky
michael tall irish porter everybody's on
stage
and we're sitting on a table
where they have
chess boards and chess sets
all set up for
each of us i think we were supposed to
take the chess sets to our room so that
we have something to train with
but we're going to go up and collect our
envelope and then
our number you know we're drawing for
the drawing of lots and everybody stood
up when their name was called
went behind each player went to the
podium pulled whatever it was a rabbit i
don't know
and went and sat back down but michael
tall
he got up
he went to the podium and when he was
returning to his chair
walked in front of everybody
and played a symbol nice
all the players what happened the
audience burst into applause they loved
it they loved it and it was really funny
the players loved it too
and we all looked around and we looked
at one another including boris baskey
and boris said only he could do that
only tall could get away with that but
nice it was nice
let's show you a little bit of a clip
because we do well not yet not yet but
we will have a clip later as we do have
anastasia carlovich with us over there
she'll be sharing clips from madrid as
we have a comparison a comparison of
last year's candidates last year yeah
that's how it feels like it feels like
eons ago we had a full world
championship match going on last year as
well but the candidates in apple won in
round number 12 he had eight points
round number 12. now he has eight and a
half he is in a situation he already
knows if he draws today for the second
time in a row
this man will qualify to the world
championship match with a round to spare
and if you qualify to two world
championship matches with a round to
spare i think we can put it to rest nepo
is very deserving extremely deserving
of
doing the rematch and how many rematch
we've had in the world championship
history we've had a lot and they've all
been fun yeah now i just want to say
something because like there's of course
there's so many talks about magnus um
not playing or
uh so what i'm thinking is can't you
just negotiate like say hey guys if you
don't do this for me i won't be playing
and i i'm sure there's going to be
negotiations
for me like
i love to negotiate coach nolan
so it's always i don't know it feels so
um
unfair to him to just keep saying he
said he won't play
i mean i'm i'm paraphrasing but
i don't know i just i want to see that
negotiation i want to see him shake feet
it down a little and be like guys this
is what i want you give it to me
but what does he want well that's
exactly the question i wanted to say uh
mvl
in an interview said uh
i understand
magnus is upset i understand he would
like to see a change
in the format
we understand that but the fact that
magnus hasn't specifically said
and these are my suggested changes get
your committees together negotiate right
but magnus hasn't come back like that
he's basically come back and said
make the system more modern
without making an exact suggestion of
what he
intends
when you speak to magnus he
he does say i i want a system that's
open fair
which is implies
he likes the knockout he likes
swiss opens
jump right in here alejandro
do you get a sense of where it is that
magnus wants to take the world of chess
my sense is that magnus is just saying
not this
whatever it is
but not this not this grueling
cycle that everybody plays for two years
you're waiting for the world champion at
the end and on top of that there's
another 12 game match or 14 actually
since they changed the regulations they
lengthened it they lengthened it and
i don't think that he's come up with and
he's come up with ideas he says he likes
this i like that but he hasn't sat down
and said this is my preferred so nothing
concrete and clear from the world
champion except
not this one whatever it is nothing this
exhausting but one of the things that he
has absolutely supported is played in
the world blitz championships
that's a swiss he's played in the world
rapid championship
that's a swiss he's played in the world
cup
the 128 player knockout of vent which
he's never won by the way but he's
enjoyed playing it and um
you you can see that he likes those
events when you see him at the world
bliss championships he's very talkative
he's very approachable
uh he likes it
not this
yeah i don't know no no i was just i
wanted to get you're in put on in my
opinion it's kind of fair like
for the world champion that's like it's
been a world champion for a number of
years to say hey guys i'm sick of this i
want to change now i if i'm not mistaken
kasparov had to change like hate this is
this current permit is what i want so
fita made that change please correct me
that's not exactly how it worked
no no who who made this it was bobby
so bobby uh he
bobby fischer yes way
before spassky
way before spassky says the system's
rotten end of story
i don't like the system he
bobby wins again a 24 game match against
boris baskey and he demands a new system
of the first to win 10 games draw is not
counting
and fide comes up with some egregiously
bad idea a compromise of six games draws
not counting so they change the rules to
six games and bobby says i'm not playing
six games so they got the worst of both
worlds
and eventually they had this 48 game
match that went five to three with gary
kasparov before it was aborted
and i think it was played in the hall of
columns in the soviet union in moscow
where they buried the general secretary
of the communist parties and
because the match took six months it was
like three guys and
the funerals were disturbing the chest
it was it was pretty
it was pretty bad
very very very strange but yeah it was
bobby who said i don't like the the
match system of 24 because what it means
is i can draw my way to victory and he
wanted to reward wins
but as karpov rightly said
if we had played a 10-game match system
we would both be in the mental hospital
he would have won
but only after 32 draws that it was
included of course but um
i mentioned kasparov because i remember
that he was not a big fan of a huge 48
game but also
i think again please correct me um that
kasparov uh wanted to have that crown
and everybody else come challenge him
but magnus is like i don't really want
the crown i want to play with everybody
else exactly so that's a big difference
yes that's style of format but there was
other problems that during gary's tenure
that was very very problematic and uh
again a big shout out to magnus i think
he's an outstanding world champion
he
likes the fact that there's a world
champion in rapid chess he likes the
fact that there's a world champion in
blitz and maybe he likes the fact that
there's a world classical
uh champion as well but in gary's time
gary was the world champion
and he felt very connected to that title
so he did not want
any other kind of world championship
whether it be blitz or rapid and he
called it immoral oh to even play a
blitz and rapid it's like immoral and
remember elijah porter saying look i'm
catholic
i mean i'm playing chess how can it be
immoral for me to play chess you can't
tell me i i i mean i'm an immoral person
and gary well okay so uh in gary's case
he didn't want to see other world
championships and uh later maybe he
softened his approach a bit
but uh for the moment
that's what i was meaning what i meant
to say when i was when i was uh at my
peak let's say there was no blitz
championships yeah it was like oh it
would have been so much fun
to see these top guys and i remember the
one blitz championship we held 1989 or
1990 i'm not really too sure in saint
john's new brunswick in canada michael
tall
won the finals against rafiq vaganyan
which was incredibly exciting and then
it was never held again
not until modern times so yeah
these world championship titles and
events
and not a whole of it very good either
it's tough uh these chess players are
tough uh alejandro don't you know it i
mean as a coach
oh man
we've been there we've been there yeah
let's update the games a little bit guys
right we do have a new thing especially
this one this is moves against duda and
check out this night on e4 you know
where you know the route this night took
yeah this night
to season it was season look at the rest
of the position by black nothing's
changed that's right not a single thing
has changed five moves this night went
to b6 went to d7 went to f8 went to h7
went to g5 attacked this queen
and then took upon him before
it did
and it's it's arrived it won a pawn but
it took so long to get there that by
this point white has developed all of
his pieces yes the pawn is a very
powerful central pawn we talked about
the sacrifice earlier the possibility of
getting rid of the pawn in order to open
avenues to the black position is it
worth a full pawn again not clear
especially not clear when you're playing
the game you will have ideas at some
point not at the moment of playing f4
and just opening up the file opening up
this bishop for the moment you can't do
that knight g3 is going to be on tap you
have to defend against that this knight
would actually rather be back on g6
absolutely it feels like you lost a
tempo or two actually as white as you
probably will have to return this guy to
its annoying square for the moment the
engines like black just a little bit
they do like the pawn rookie 8 was
played i think an incredibly logical
move at some point black is going to
hint at a break with b5 because you
don't need to be up a point you need to
actually create a plan in your game
for the moment b5 will be on tap but you
can imagine king j8 is going to be
played first just to tuck the king away
from the action the engines like the
pawn
i'm not so sure how good black's
position is compared to white i think
it's just a dynamic double-edged
position in which white has compensation
but the engines don't agree with me as
much they think you know what a pawn is
a pawn and in this case you really
haven't proven as much they like black a
little bit alejandro i hate to cut you
but i believe
never mind i was going to say there's
going to be a draw and
they were repeating i guess
tame or phobia no no it's a it's a draw
it's it's it's just a uh djt oh it has
to be a nobody plays kingy for fighting
right
i would love to see that no this game is
over i'm sure that there was some kind
of repetition right and then they put
the king in the middle of the board they
put the king in the middle of the board
yeah i haven't seen it come up as a draw
half
quite yet on my board but yeah we do
expect that that game and
by the way
you know like once again boldly stating
the obvious that is
a result that hurts both players i mean
uh
a draw just gets them nowhere and for
ding lauren and ikaru they're both
saying well done guys good good good
good job
looking at this being like a win today
dingleran's not gonna win this no let me
not jinx that but i don't think he's
winning this no
hicara wins today all he needs is a draw
all he needs is to survive tomorrow
yeah well he'll have to play dingler in
it i guess that but that's it right
right because ding won't catch him no
matter because he's playing hikaru
kikaro's got second place in his hands
if he wins today super sharp position
super fun game it's all on hikaru
nakamura to see if he can get second
place i apologize just a second
hold on hi karu and ding come into this
round tie for first yes because exactly
but let's let's say yeah tonight for a
second hikaru wins
ding
draws hikaru's only got a half a point
lead
playing hikaru tomorrow you mean
carl plays ding tomorrow with only a
half a point lead yes
yeah but they could surpass
hikaru with the victory that's why i'm
saying hikar needs to draw
tomorrow
tomorrow right
and that's it because ding would only
get half a point yes okay good sorry
yeah yeah i think i missed i i i
misheard you then i i i'm sorry there
because i thought what you were saying
was that uh hikaru with a win secure no
no it doesn't secure still needs a draw
tomorrow but he's saying it's in my
hands right right he looks at the
tournament says i don't have to depend
on anybody's results anymore if i can
take this tournament in my hands he's
gonna do so you know that he's gonna go
super solid tomorrow but he still has to
win today's game not that he's any
better
no we're not saying that we just think
it's a double-edged position he must be
happy about what he got right on the
board whether it's good it's bad it
doesn't matter he needs to figure out a
way to make this a dynamic game and a
dynamic game he is making down a pawn
for the moment but i'm sure that he
feels the compensation king j8 has been
played already let's see where hikaru
puts in the pressure to trip over the
polish superstar because at the moment
the engines still think black is
completely fine
move play the move b4 which is a very
committal move weakening c4 but
pretending that both b5 and c5 are
immediate threats they're not but you
will be
facing as black this potentially
fascinating game thankfully because it's
the only interesting game that we really
have super interesting super interesting
making up for the fact that this is
going nowhere
and this
okay this is still a game okay true
kind of
not that much of a game nice timing
plays the movement check forces he takes
f4 you have to take back with the rook i
guess right and after a bit i mean this
is pretty dead yeah right c3
blunders no no
oh i mean this is this is again huge
favorite draw right yeah a huge favor
you have this ugly structure yeah but
you actually have to keep pieces
and this is where we stand no
we have one game finished already yes
both timor and fabiano you can see them
have caught up with karen dingley and
they're both in second place that won't
last because i don't think baron is
going to lose
and well hicaro might i don't know
that's a three result game right but at
the very least one of the players uh
currently tied for a second will make it
to clear second
uh fabian team where it looks from the
current standings that they did each
other a favor the contrary they did each
other at the service as they are now
depending on other players to see if
they can reach second place
yeah no i completely completely agree as
we get ready to take a break we've got
to tell you that we have a very special
guest coming up in studio this time not
any skype calls or any of that good
stuff
international master eric rosen will be
joining us we'll see you on the other
side of the break
[Music]
hey st louis the ascension charity
classic presented by emerson is back
this september don't miss the excitement
when the pga tour champions best compete
again all for charity september 9th
through the 11th at norwood hills
country club pro-am spots hospitality
packages vip tickets and more available
now at ascensioncharityclassic.com
[Music]
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament these are our live standings
with one game
already recorded that was the game
between timor rajabov and fabiano they
made a draw it was a good fight bobby
came up with a
different
opening take with the black pieces he he
offered a gambit of three pawns wasn't
accepted timor and fabi draw
they have six and a half points three
games remaining two
look like they're very even
one very very interesting but i'm very
happy to be sitting next to
international master eric rosen eric
welcome to the show oh thanks
i think this is the first time we've
ever done this together i think so guys
it feels pretty surreal to be here i
feel bad kicking away dorsa from your
seat but uh i feel bad that you kicked
away
as well but it's very nice to have you
uh obviously you're a local and for
folks who don't know you um
international master and
i think you do a great job with your
stream really a big shout out to you
no no no it's really really good for
those of you don't know and address our
audience if you will tell us what you
got right
about this candidates and your
predictions oh dear i've uh well i've
been doing like these uh like the
chess.com channel point predictions uh
at the start of each broadcast ask every
day how many draws there will be
and i i usually predict like three or
four draws but there's been so many
rounds with uh three more decisive games
so it's it's been a thrill to watch
and very difficult to predict um i think
in the beginning i i really thought
foddy would have a uh
a
good shot of coming on top and right
okay he was in the
two of our top two for a while felt the
same way
varusian and
christian both picked fabi
in fact as their
top picks and
only dorset got nefa but she came in a
week late
it was unfair that she got to pick uh
when the tournament was half uh
over
gary kasparov made a very salient point
that
he should have
known that nepal was going to be
successful
because of his training that he had at
the world championship match he's
carrying all of the ideas and all of the
enthusiasm and the energy
that he wasn't able to demonstrate in
dubai and that's true that that carried
him very well for this event
did nepo's
nepo's success surprise you
um in hindsight i think it's less
surprising given that he's just so well
prepared in the opening and i think the
change in the time format also uh
helped him a little bit because he's one
of the quicker players of uh of the
field exactly and he's putting his
opponents under like serious pressure uh
right out of the opening and there's so
many games where his opponents are
making of unprovoked mistakes
where uh they feel the pressure on the
clock and from very early in the game so
uh i think it's easy to say in hindsight
but yeah
yeah big kudos to him just taking a
massive lead and looks like he's about
to clinch it today no question about it
as he plays quickly puts pressure on his
opponent we have a colleague in madrid
anastasia
who caught up with magnus carlson i'll
get your reactions to this interview
[Music]
uh magnus what are your comments about
this
candidate's tournament and jan's
performance in particular
he's playing very well uh
uh
making the most of his his chances
like uh
there have been many interesting games
but he's uh
converted all of his advantages very
well uh and saved bad positions so he's
been by far the best
yeah i mean did you expect it to happen
no i didn't expect it i thought he was
um
criminally underrated by um
by pundits and and betting odds but i
still thought that dean and fabiano were
even bigger favorites but kudos he's
done really well
is it going to affect somehow your
decisions to play the match or not what
do you think about it now
we'll see yes okay thank you very much
for your comment
we're going to call magnus the artful
dodger
that's right on that one as he dodged
the question by the way guys sorry to
interrupt you but speaking of
this potential world championship match
it's potentially in the books
janupomniochi has drawn his game against
richard report and that is the end of
the tournament nobody can catch nepo
officially the winner of the 2022
candidates he got his magic number
already nine points out of 13. we'll see
if he adds more tomorrow 48 000 euros
and whatever mathematical seven times
whatever points he gets
we'll play for the 2023 world
championship match we don't guarantee
it's going to be against magnus carlsen
but we do guarantee that this man janine
pomnyachi is in it
hot tip
very very very deserving uh alejandro
was mentioning earlier that there's
actually few players just a few players
who have
been back-to-back
uh candidates winners and they include
for example vasily smislov he
he won the candidates in his first match
against uh bod vinnick ended up with a
tie and then he came comes back
to uh play bob vinick again and win but
then losing a rematch
and then there was um
um
vishy anand
who yeah who did that uh your quick take
it's quite an accomplishment i'm
actually wondering is this like a record
of the highest score in the candidates
for a 14-round event
already only only um
vessel and topolof remember in the
it wasn't it was actually the world
championship in san luis argentina uh
that vessel in scored six and a half
out of seven in the first half
and then you know coasted the rest away
drew drew his way to the world
championship uh title
uh but yeah that this is a th this is a
really really great score
draws tomorrow i believe it's going to
be the highest for candidates you didn't
mention the world championship match
candidates if yes if he adds that final
extra point half point sorry half point
tomorrow remember he didn't do that last
time right he lost him he qualified he
was celebrate
but dingley wren said you know what
thank you for your celebration i'll take
a full point of you before we go back
and the question is if he's going to be
able to do so tomorrow because he is
black against duda
and if he gets at half point is the
highest ever on a 14-round double uh
round-robin tournament
for the candidates but of course this is
a modern system only 10 years old
right going back to 2013. um
alejandro
your quick take on magnus the artful
dodger uh on the question of
anastasia asked about the match and he
said something like we'll see and then
i think it's what's buzzing around
social media it's what's buzzing around
the chess world ever since nepo started
running away with it why because
specifically magnus said i'm not so
interested in a rematch i've already
played a bunch of these guys i'd like a
new challenge that's what he said and a
lot of people were eyeing alireza
ferrugia as that potential new blood new
challenge coming into the new generation
of chess players to challenge magnus a
lot of people thought even though magnus
is not pinpointing to anybody in the
field who could he possibly be talking
about right when he's referring to not
wanting to play the same people again i
mean nepo has to be high on that list
and that ignites this talk that we are
having right now eric what is your take
that you have all these contacts on
social media all of these streamers that
are more aware of what's going on behind
the scenes what is your take that team
magnus has in at the moment yeah i
really wish i had more inside
information um i that's why we brought
you on the show by the way so we're
putting on this much you don't run out
of guests between right exactly we sure
did come on i reckon
um but yeah i think it'll be really
interesting to see and uh like even
though the
tournament is over for uh running of the
first place right um there's gonna be a
very
heated fight for for second place uh as
we see hikaro still playing and i think
it would be really really cool to see
hikaru
finish in second
and then it creates this dynamic where
if magnus declines to play
a world championship events right that's
nicely you could see a caro versus napo
world champion championship
um let's keep in mind hikaru is
primarily focused on streamer streaming
and not uh competitive chess these
days that would be uh super cool to see
and i think the fans would really enjoy
that as well quick question for you
erica for those of you for those of you
who aren't aware that eric has his own
stream his own channel
it's on twitch
yeah right yeah it's on youtube i live
stream on twitch and then post kind of
the best moments from my streams on
youtube so
uh yeah it's
kind of two different platforms that
work well together and i've been doing
it for uh
it's approaching the the five year mark
um five years this fall it will be five
years gosh that goes by fast right yeah
and i got my kind of introduction to
doing online content through the st with
chess club right uh doing like the
residency position and having the
lectures being posted online and um
yeah i really enjoyed it
the educational aspect and kind of
interacting with the community so it's
it's been super fun eric i think you do
a great job i really genuinely do check
out i am eric rosen on his uh
twitch stream twitch.tv slash iamrozy
there you go you you'll enjoy his uh
lectures his stream very very much so
like to throw to you alejandro your take
on the move knight g4 by hikaru
compensation for the pond
that's where we're at right now yasser
because knight g4 played the engines are
giving zero so we don't care about their
evaluation this one is a fascinating
struggle it does seem that black's pawn
is strong and central when we talk about
extra pawns in the center we almost
always are determining how good are
these pawns in controlling different
squares you see the pawn on e5 controls
d4 controls f1 upon e6 controls d5 and
f5 what's the issue with these pawns
they're not mobile you the moment you
start pushing them the weaker they
become so
white is using the advantage of the fact
that these pawns can move in order to
threaten breaks like c5 threading breaks
like f4 bring the rook on the third rank
and for that
black needs to get rid of at least one
of these knights and that's why the move
knight g4 is currently on the board this
knight is happy to trade itself on f6
sometimes you talk about the superfluous
knights these are not superfluous
knights the knight on e4 is not
particularly stable it's not anchored
and it's not like the knight on f6
doesn't have a job in this case it's
attacking h5 therefore hikaru wants to
get rid of one knight in order to
increase his pressure knight g4 i think
is a very good move both players are
still have plenty of time only 12
minutes until sorry 12 moves until time
control and here there's a bunch of
moves for black you could take on g4 you
could go bishop d8 as the engine wants
to do
just to give the rook more space
not a clear plan that i can find for
black to improve his position on the
other hand you look at the position that
black has right now ultra ultra solid
difficult to make any headway on the
queen side or on the king side as all of
black's pawns are very nicely defended
uh just to play devil's advocate for a
moment it seems to me like this move
knight g4 is connected
with the move f2 f4 so if we see a move
like a5 a4 let's put it on the board
it's just played by the move a5 so a4 is
a logical follow-up yes right and then
if you take on f6 knight f6
now there's no knight g3 and therefore
i'm thinking white wants to play f4 i
think this is potentially where we're
headed now i cannot take on f4 because
this is just devastating right whoops
yeah and this is where prophylactical
thinking comes into play what is
prophylactical thinking is when you use
prophylaxis the idea that you're going
to play against your opponent's threats
you're going to preempt what your
opponent wants to do and that
would be the move bishop d8 here and i
think that's why bishop d8 is very
highly considered by the computer
because when you take take yes f4 is
well
f4 is still on tap but what's the
difference i have defended
my pawn on e6 this is prophylactical
thinking what does my opponent want to
do with the previous move yasser you
said it yourself knight takes f6 knight
takes f6 f4 this is how hikar wants to
break in the position so i'm going to
put my bishop on d8 so that i can take
on f4 and now my queen is not attacking
on e6 because my rook is defending now
does the game go on the game goes on
right nothing lost knight takes f4 you
still have pressure against the pawn so
you go e5 you lose control of d5 is that
enough for the pawn do you have queen f7
instead the game flares anew but it
makes more sense for black than in the
position with a4 and of course duda he's
kind of good at chess
bishop d8 played
wow
great stuff and this is again i mean
this is the key game
of the round because again we do feel
that the game between
uh ali reza and ding loren
is still headed towards a draw yan
thanks to his draw or again uh
just an absolutely
masterful play by nepo as he really
put his signature on this event maybe
the event of his career really it was
just that good i mean just everything
went so well for him
as uh he's unassailable and with the two
games remaining
uh dingler and bishop e two to b5
trying to get my head around that last
move by in the few months that i've been
gone i come back and
nepo is the champion yes
yes
yeah yeah but
but
eric rosen by the way uh
it took your place and he was very
apologetic and i said he should have
been i mean i much preferred you sitting
next to me thank you
who let that guy in here i just want to
mention that guess who was right
hello shameless it's just like i i don't
understand how you actually stand behind
that desk i'd say that
nepal was like a 14-point lead in a 12
in a two-round tournament and she's like
you know what
she she comes in
at the halfway score nepal was leading
nobody picked the poor guy oh good
points oh good point yeah yeah four guys
right now drowning in champagne
somewhere in madrid
he is now
for a second time in a row challenger he
might not even be the challenger because
we don't know who he's playing but he
will at least be participating in the
world championship match what a
situation for nepo where he takes all of
these haters from dubai and let's be
honest he gained a lot of these haters
for his play over the board
deservedly right this was a terrible
world championship sure it was one of
the most forgettable ones that we've had
in a while
and he comes in with the opportunity to
rectify the ship
to say i belong and i'm going to do it
better this time exactly this was such a
great performance by yande pomnyacchia
we see where the round was starting uh
today and over there in madrid thanks to
nastia for sharing all of these
man what a great performance by nepal
what a way to finish the event just
cruised through the entire thing when we
talk about candidates tournaments you
rarely talk about people cruising
through it right but nepo
was just on a different level yes he
really really was the only player to go
undefeated
and
for chess pros
they put a lot
a lot into that type of effort you win a
championship
yeah well done you win a championship
undefeated it's a totally different
let's not jinx it he could still lose
yeah yeah yeah so far but uh he's
already secured his first place
and we've got to admire uh his
achievement it it was really
really something fantastic
on the other hand so we've had a day so
far two draws i it's a four night that
should also be a draw
unless
blunder but
i don't see
water i'm just thinking that ali reza is
really looking forward to trying uh
the moment before d4
so uh we're going to make a move for uh
dingleran so ali reza is really looking
forward to this idea of playing the move
rook to d1 where he can menace
bishop to c4
and if we could get a position i mean it
takes some conniving let's put it like
that but if we could get a position
where black is getting tied up
in this kind of way at least he can
start to think should i be playing for
b4 maybe maybe not
should i be playing for g
six maybe maybe not but maybe the extra
pawn is meaningful and therefore
we saw the move d4 instead
before white can play rook c1 rook
pardon me before white could play rook
to d1 and bishop c4 he gets in d4
and
ready to meet rook d1 with d3 so i
why do i do this
because he's thinking that maybe
sorry my my uh my face is because of
pawn c3 why why am i helping my
opponents get d4 couldn't i just keep
upon aceto and just
chill
oh yeah earlier again uh i don't think
white is taking any risks
of losing none
at all
you're stuck
what's your next move are you gonna are
you gonna move this pawn
are you gonna move this font
are you gonna move this bishop
uh fair so
are you gonna move your king
the question i think that ali reza is
going to ask or answer himself is what
about if i sacrifice my bishop i have
three pawns
okay check to the king
where would you like to go dorso would
you six okay e6 looks like a good square
comfy square
good for you if i go check
let's say i just go king
d6
okay and now i go rook
here
so this is what ali reza is asking
himself is he
he's got three connected past pawns but
this bishop if this pawn was on h5 it'd
be a different story this bishop is
actually really in the way it's a
strangely enough it actually turned out
to be very very well placed so before i
you know
jump
to the e5 square and swallow
the loss of this pawn i could maybe
preface
the move rook e5 now again i've got
three pawns for a bishop i personally
don't think that this will
turn
will i don't think this will be a
successful line of play for white
um
in fact this pawn is hardly an extra
pawn right it's just sort of like it
makes it difficult and this pawn is not
really
a great pawn either in other words i
might be playing for a loss
that's my point by by playing uh the
sacrifice but on the other hand i don't
think
and we'll get alejandro's take i don't
think that
ali reyes is taking risk uh one question
i might ask
uh
um
alejandro is how does the computer
engine evaluate takes takes b4
any chances i'm scared i don't want this
position
this is not my fortnite
this is not your easy draw
oh alejandro that's a bit playing for a
loss it is yeah the the problem is i
think pawn takes b4 is just a draw but i
think i'd rather take black the problem
i think is d3 and then you have to solve
some tactical issues the engines still
say it's holdable
but you gotta i want to take the pawn
yeah but then i got
e3 see i see your idea you can take take
and this is defended
but this bishop is helping this spawn
after e2 you just don't defend
so pawn takes d3 starts asking salient
questions is this is this a draw
the engines say yes but
i mean you got to go down the variations
i think the moment you get here you stop
calculating you're like i'm done
calculating that's not going to work so
cd i think presents some risk for white
the moment you want you
untangle my king right so that it can
run to c3 in some variations i think i'm
a little scared the engines already say
that you you got to play rook d1
d3 and for zero zero just take on d3
play the move c4 and black can't do
anything white can't do anything either
just keep the rook on the third rank
this bishop's not going anywhere i don't
know if it was where is it going and
you're never going to get it's just a
draw like bishop takes the three zero
zero zero if you go king h1 i was trying
to make the worst move on the position
i still don't know how black wins
the engine says decisive advantage but
it gets stuck at some point
i haven't figured out how you win this
as black i was even trying to go like
rook takes b5 here of course nobody's
gonna play king h1 but this was kind of
my point how dangerous does this get out
of a bunch of pawns i get my king to c5
this is past
engine zero zero of course
and nobody's gonna play king h1 ever i
think that you go rook d1 and you give
up the piece but then that's the end of
your winning attempts it's white right
uh if you don't play rook d1 and you
don't play sea takes d4 though i'm not
really sure why you've encouraged me to
do all of these things as black again i
expect something like this to just
completely hold
uh you go king e7 but you're you're
really stuck right i can play i think
rook f1 rook d1 back
even if you get your pawn to d2 you're
not making progress right but
who's playing for a win
see that's my point can someone explain
to me why
why c3 happened for white i thought we
explained that c3 you you're trying to
prepare this idea of bishop b5 and c4
but why is it is it a good idea that's a
different question why can't i just
chill with my bishop to school bishop
box cause he's playing for a win i mean
black white's playing for a win why play
it for night
i i i think my brain is going error
error
but you got you got a point and already
does this very often right you see the
positions changed and you try for
something is he over reaching that's the
difference right that's that's where the
question is i don't know uh i'd rather
take black hours i was gonna take black
from the beginning of the end game
anyway but i still don't think he's like
overstepped or anything he's well within
drawing reaches well well well within
if i was a testing woman i would have
bet he's gonna shoot himself in not fun
places right now right
um
but you you were pointing out what i
thought was a really really fun uh
ending
um
our john our friend jonathan mostell
always liked these uh dragon variations
where he could sacrifice as a rook for
like
like four or five pawns
but you had a position there that i
really liked alejandro which went b4 yes
d3 yes
i take the pawn
you go here okay
i go
here
you go here i go here you go a rook a8
i take a bomb yay
you make a queen oh black's running out
of puns yes he is
uh and i just you know like had this
flash of uh
you know three connected past pawns but
again this i mean it it makes such a
difference that this pawn on h3 is not
working
um
get four pawns for a rook
how about you are you playing for a
winner for no
play you play for the loss i think i
played for a loss the more you analyze
positions for white yeah if you kill the
game or you play for a loss
i think at this point
in this kind of end games you eventually
get to this intersection like you can
mess around with the position you can
mess around with the position but at
some point especially when these guys
start rolling you start to figure out
what is your risk factor here right how
much willing uh how much are you willing
to risk in this particular position
objectively saying this is an acceptable
risk this is an unacceptable risk the
violation that you showed to me seems
like an unacceptable risk because i'm
playing for two results as white and
neither of them is winning
so
you know the rook sometimes wins the
rook will sometimes overpower the three
pawns sure uh but the pawns are not
gonna promote they're just not there's
yeah so why go for that line right and i
think that's what the youngster is
considering right now now let's go to
the other game okay at the moment uh
rook d3 played we had a few moves knight
g4 we saw bishop d8 expect expected and
good knight takes f6 only move is knight
takes don't take with the bishop because
the knight on e4 needs defense
rook d2
okay rook d2 logical but
i guess he wants to play rook d1 right
let's let him do that
i like 97 returning the knight to good
squares i also like that this bishop can
hint to go to g5 exploit the fact that
this rook's on d2 i like this okay rook
fd1 bishop g5 played
and rook d3 is the current situation on
the board the engines are saying
decisive black advantage because b5
decisive black advantage not the biggest
it's like 1.7 bucks and we've got b5 on
the board uh
yeah i guess
well you can't take
this is a big issue
i assume this wins yeah this wins
double attack you don't have d2
available
so what do you do here
bishop a3 yeah but
the
change of structure right after b4 yeah
this has to favor black getting this
pawn all the way to b4 must favor black
yeah i think that's a huge success
actually for black to have already
gotten that in and with the temple right
right and with the tempo
could we go back to the position where
with the bishop on d8 why didn't hikaru
play f4
in that position where they just traded
knights f4
you take on f4 i assume
i can take on f6
that secures that locks in my knight on
g6 that you could never challenge the
knight
i'll go rook takes and i want to go rook
e4 and try to force e6 e5
how does a computer assess
better for black not much
0.6.7
but better for black it is a pawn and
perhaps you are playing a bit of hope
chess that you're gonna force that pawn
to move it is pretty behind uh enemy
lines and rooksy's five will remind you
that you have an h pawn so that after
rookie four rookie four i'll just defend
this guy actually doesn't even defend it
because rook g5
doesn't even defend he doesn't even
defend it because if you take on e6 here
check
takes on h5 is made right
so you're getting made it here good
point so you don't have time to do any
of these things perhaps that's why
hikaru didn't see those variations as
favorable now the more
pertinent question to what hikaru is
doing is that after rook d29 d7 you kind
of see this bishop coming
and here maybe you play f4
okay maybe here you play f4 rook d1 the
engines really didn't like because
because of this sequence that after
bishop g5 you've gotten rid of your
control over f4 you can't play f4 as
well you don't have enough defenders and
the moment this rook moves b5 is such a
difficult move to me brook c2 is yeah
ruxin is just so strong right and i i
mean i think i'm taking that pawn
i think if you leave it for free i'll
take that pawn well that was why i was
playing bishop a3 right just to try to
close what what
what else do you have
i think you have to right i think you
have to play bishop a3 what
what's he called planning here
it's kind of an ugly move though bishop
a3 is such an ugly move give up c5
giving up two tempi
to give up the c5 square is unnatural
you do it out of necessity
right but he might he might be pigeon
holed into it right now because if you
don't attack d6 what do you do
i've been doing a little bit of
calculation in my head could we get
standing for a minute
so if my calculation is
working let's say naka loses let's say
ding wins the way fear is just playing
poor kid
and then i mean that's a big idea
and then dang and naka are playing
together let's say the waifu is just
playing fabi wins let's say dink runs
out of luck he loses we get another
three-way seven and a half for fabi
dinganaka is my math correct that your
math is correct on that one
there's more than one way in which we
can get
who has a higher name
whose name is more alphabet
exactly exactly oh so yeah that's that's
so you ask what knockout is doing naka
is giving his countryman another shot
i'm gonna go go on i'm gonna go with
fabi on the alphabet there yeah uh b5 uh
take us through the ramifications once
again of bishop a3 again i'm i'm
breaking through on d6 so you certainly
don't have the right to take and allow
rook take so i'm thinking you play b4
i go back yeah you can post up knight c5
and uh for the moment your pawns
aren't really moving anywhere well move
them first go e4 first at what moment
right now right now e4 first okay i was
kind of going across anyway just keep
them moving
d5 it's the same issue you don't have c
takes d5 we already know this c takes d5
runs into rural c2 it just moves a piece
you can't take so now i'm establishing
my center now i'm threatening to play
knight or bishop to f6 and start
consolidating my position
yeah i'm sorry i just kind of stopped
myself here because
it's
it it feels like
i'm coffee housing
the question is this isn't a coffee
house game this is the candidates true
is this really going to work we've seen
attacks that people start sacrificing
some material they just don't pan out
right and this one it is an exchange and
it's not a whatever exchange this is a
full exchange right once you get that
pawn on g5 it's still a full exchange
i feel that this is a game where
nerves the
the the ability to control and remain
calm
is going to be so
critical and
what plays into that is the time
pressure uh dorsa uh
how were the uh
is time trouble going to be a uh
impactful in this uh game well from what
i've seen evo has 32 uh sorry naka has
32 and
that's a lot yeah duda has 27 minutes
and they both need like eight per move
so i don't think time pressure is going
to be too big of a deal but
in the other game
in the other game between
uh ali reza and dingle i mean they're
also very close to time control and they
did go down this line of sacrificing
peace sacrifices
dink is 50 right
again i mean they're all very close to
40. i don't think anything is going to
change where they will get their second
type of still not over the fact that
fortnite led to this i'm sorry i'm just
a little you can never lose it as white
you can never lose it
uh because your bishop is trapped your
bishop is just trapped i'll put my king
for example on f1 and i can go king f1
king e2
and your bishop can't move out your king
is not going to like okay imagine that
you gave yourself a lot of moves you
would have to move your king all the way
here then you'd have to move your bishop
out of the way then you'd have to move
your king in
and you still
yeah exactly and you still haven't uh
you know crossed into my camp so in a
sense
your bishop is playing a great defensive
role your king is playing a great
defensive role
and your rook will you know
keep my rook tied up so
i don't think white's taking any risks
but on the other hand
if he
wanted to use his extra pawnee i i don't
think he he did it in the right way
i think you said it already alejandro
but just to confirm this feels like
triple zeros to me the first time i'll
agree with a computer on a triple zero
score
yep yep we'll take that thank you
alejandra you're welcome you're very
welcome for that analysis
you know
he chirps in you know like you make this
wonderful you know gettysburg address
kind of speech and he goes you're right
yeah you're nice
right what do you want me to add
i'm just telling you the engines agree
with everything that you've said yasser
it's a triple zero you can't play c4 you
can also give a check it really does not
matter okay as long as you get this move
c4 in well you will you can't really
play king d5 you can but then this
position becomes wild
this one we play for three results
because you don't get c3 immediately and
your king is not on the right side of
the board
now is that necessary no you can just
play the move uh c4 which was played
into the game
immediately
and that's it
that's that's pretty much it you can go
rook d5 rookie five at some point risk
it for the biscuit it should end in a
draw no matter what you're gonna run out
of pawns as black
but you don't really queen these guys
either especially since the king is on
the king's side right you're not you're
not really going to promote the g-pawn
definitely not promoting the h-pawn who
are you promoting you're going to have
to play rook d5 rookie 5 take this guy
you have a bunch of pawns but they take
forever engines say triple zero that is
nobody nobody's surprised
there's several ways to do it for white
you just you can just move back and
forth with the king no real reason or
you can give checks with rookie three
rook d3 nothing to do about that right
but if you want to play for a win you
can play rook d5 the engines say it's
okay you can't play for a win rook d5 it
won't change the outcome of the game
okay do you have that in farsi
um what
risk it for the biscuit
[Laughter]
risk it for the visit i haven't heard
i i don't know where i picked that one
up you know
bar has had a lot of these fun little
i know there's a loosey goosey there was
a
this brisket biscuit i i've heard a lot
of these through my teammates who heard
it through var or
so
prince correct me if um
risk it for the biscuit you heard you
heard it here first folks uh after b5
let's jump into the game of hikaru where
really all of the action is at
alejandro
you scared me there with this
blunder alert rook d1 move by hikaru and
you're saying that the engines really
like black and the extra pawn yeah i
mean it's a game okay but it is a game
that i think everybody would take black
in the pawn starts becoming more and
more relevant
you get all your pieces to the correct
squares what's pl what's white's take
right i get b4 knight c5 especially when
i get queen f7 in right i think once you
get a consolidating move that's a
consolidating if i can play queen f7
with this pawn defended yeah everything
is secure you don't get an f4 i get
queen f5 in i get pressure on h5 that's
kind of the key if i can re-maneuver my
pieces in a way that you're no longer
attacking my pawn on d6 that's the end
of your counter play because you're not
playing for f4 it's very hard to achieve
in this position this knight is between
annoying and stuck you're not really
sure which one it is right the knight on
g6 is annoying because like takes e5 is
a thread it's controlling a lot of
squares around my king
but it's not coming back right and it's
not participating directly with any
other piece for the moment yes with the
pressure on e5 i can't play d5 annoying
again but instead you doing something
immediate not so clear to the engines
hikaru on a deep think after the move b5
i wouldn't be surprised if he's shaking
his head because i think it'll start to
dawn on him that this maneuver of rook
d2 rook d3 rook d1 first took too much
time and second tactically he's played
bishop a3 second tactically it's forcing
him to shed even more tempe to his
opponent right
um
sorry
at times when i get in positions like
hikaru is in right now
well i
kind of look for a um
parachute you know pull the rip cord get
me out of here sometimes that involves a
sacrifice
is queen f3 completely ridiculous uh the
idea is that if you take the pawn yes
uh i was
planning to sacrifice my queen
take on d6 because on a good day
if i can ever play rook takes d7 and
bishop takes e5 again i feel like i'm
free wheeling kind of coffee housing it
here
uh but
was there a bailout
solution like that we know bishop a3 has
been played
the engines are starting to wonder why
we play chess
it says get out of here it says minus
seven get out of what on earth like what
what
no not working you're you're like that
lost so rook takes d6 yeah every move
wins but every move every move wins like
every move wins queen e4 is mine but if
you want to be precise about it be
precise me quick this is just winning i
take it and i go c3
oh so much for your threads i don't get
to play bishop e5 and rook g7 maybe you
get like you have to play nothing i get
to play nothing i mean it's just dead
right yeah we don't have to look at this
that's good
fritz used to laugh at the moves when
the move was bad yeah that was like a
terrible programmer
i thought that was fun it would crush
spirit of anybody who wanted to use
engine there you go problem solved yeah
problem solved yeah this doesn't work at
all bishop a3 on the board because there
is no alternative you cannot allow black
to take on c4 you gotta force the move
b4 yeah because d6 is an even bigger
threat losing c4 is not as relevant as
losing d6
i assume the move b4 comes on the board
i cannot imagine another move
something to be said about d5 but i
think you kind of give up that idea
pretty quickly right you can't imagine
so i expect b4 to come in the board
pretty soon fascinating struggle still
an extra pawn for black doesn't mean
it's a one game
but it does give advantage black okay
and in the other game ali reza did try
to play the move rook d5 and that got
quickly answered by the move king g6 yes
you're welcome to munch
this pawn and this pawn but i'm not
going to give you up give up this pawn
without some work rook takes b3
uh ali reza could just return
sorry
no no dar
i just want to be
funny here and say rook d6 kingdoms 5
rook h6 checkmate yes of course those
are always
beautiful checkmating patterns that will
win you points in a puzzle rush i
promise you they will show you that
pattern
i'm assuming the king will just drop
back
and we do have some moves on the board
yeah so ali raza
did make this whole bishop
sacrifice hoping that he was going to
win and he's played rook takes c5 and
rook takes b3 on the board
still i'm assuming again just triple
zeroes across the whole spectrum here
can i eat the other pan you can you can
also give it it doesn't matter the
thread of rook g3 recap 3 is so
dangerous for white
right this is how we lose yeah
and here you're still on time
even here you're still on time but
you're still wondering why
why why because like flirting flirting
with disaster right yeah
so which is why he played check now can
i keep checking
yeah i think that's what you're gonna
end up doing that's what he's going to
to do is keep checking and
black on the other hand does not want to
see that f5 pawn disappear especially
not with a check and there's that and
especially not with a check so he's not
crossing over to the f do not play for a
win with some egregiously bad move like
king f8 because
that will cost you the pawn with a check
now white has four pawns let's say for
the piece when i take f5 and a5 yeah
losing chances and suddenly what are you
doing yeah yeah so i expect this to be a
perpetual right now right exactly on the
board again we'll return to hikaru's
game
because again uh we didn't really kind
of complete our thought
which was that
bishop
back to b2
kind of seems to encourage d
e for pardon me and d4 and there's
always this rook c2 the more i'm looking
at it alejandro i hate my bishop on b2 i
feel like
i'm constantly
a target for the rook coming to c2 does
bishop c1
in any way change the eval yeah it makes
it worse for white that's my fear yeah
so the problem is that this bishop even
though it's kind of locked in right it
is
let's call it spiritually preventing me
from putting the pawns on light squares
yeah because i give up the entire
diagonal what happens the moment that
you give up the bishops that i take take
and i'm much happier to advance on the
center and since i can do it immediately
with their e4 with e4 taking advantage
of the fact that takes runs into this
fork right um
you do it immediately and when the rook
moves i don't know rook d1 whatever i
followed up with d5 taking advantage
again of tactics your rook on c1 is
hanging no matter where the rook on d3
went your rook on c1 is hanging which
means i can follow it up with d5 d5 i
have a pass pawn already on d5 which is
currently defended it was extra controls
a lot of squares the knight comes to f6
in a much safer route i don't have to
worry about this bishop on g5 getting
trapped via f4 or having to return to
the game
i don't think that you frustrating yeah
it's a little frustrating but i don't
think that you can exchange bishops as
white i think you have to stick it back
on b2 okay continue bishop b2 e4
which is not forced right you can start
with knight c5 i think mostly
so where's my rook going g3 rook g3 yeah
actually the engine wants to take on e4
but i don't think it's sacrificed
exchange yeah again it does think why
this black is on the verge of winning so
it does engine like resources to tight
to try to hold the evaluation back it's
not what the humans do it's not how you
assess this position humans are very
afraid of what we call permanent
advantages
some things are temporary advantages and
you can try to get your way out of
things initiatives potential double
attacks potential threats temporary
advantages permanent advantage is like
an exchange it's for the rest of the
game
so you are very
like a pawn
you're very
not happy about giving it up so queen
takes e4 not a very human approach to
chess uh rook g3 is the human approach i
think
d5 has to be played is the only way to
secure the pattern e4 again if you
played e4 you do have to follow it up
with d5 you take advantage of the
problems on c2 you could sacrifice the
exchange here it's still what the engine
wants to do probably a better way to do
so than in the previous move okay and
now you have to find queen d2 you play
queen g4 uh the engine just says you
know what
keep taking stuff
no problems on the king side it looks a
little bit challenging there's rook
takes d7 and h6 there's queen takes g5
and h6 there's h6 immediately engines
don't care decisive advantage black
already minus 3.4 going even further
meanwhile the ding already game is over
as we more or less expected
check on c7 and c6 no reason for the
youngster to risk any more than he has
he took it to the verge oh yes he did
but this is the end this is the end
really you cannot risk any more than
this you just can't start taking on a5
and give up the f4 pawn uh dingler and
also should not cross into the f file
that's why the engines give zero zero
the ev the players think so as well and
the game is over
clear second place right now for dingley
ren depending on the game of hikaru
and for hikaru's fans they're saying a
score today would be magnificent but
they're beginning
to sweat
yeah that their guy is losing and
it may require tomorrow
that karu wins and once again reminding
everyone that
carl plays against sting loren but
hikaru will have black
is that right that sounds right yep
that sounds right here it comes that's a
big deal at this level we got the round
14 coming up beautiful there it is
dingler in if he goes into tomorrow's
game with a half a point lead
wow i mean with white right that's the
thing
that's the big thing that's why hikaru
is trying so hard today exactly
he wants that half point for himself
because he knows he's black he knows
that his repertoire is very solid he
knows his repertoire is vulnerable in
positions where he needs a win right he
doesn't want to need a win he wants to
be able to come into the game tomorrow
comfortable that a draw is okay
dorsa when you missed the first half of
the event we were
genuflecting on the fact that
dingleran was in the cellar oh my god he
was yes the whole first half he had lost
his opening game with the white pieces
against nepo and things weren't going
better
that suddenly had a 3-0 run and he could
be in second place potentially playing
for a world championship match
uh this is a phoenix rising from the
ashes it was really really really bad
but he's turned the ship
around completely it's a remarkable
tournament it does feel like a
cinderella story it does it really
really really does and once again here's
our standings with three rounds three
games completed uh dorsal thank you
yasir well nepo has won congratulations
to him absolutely ding is in claire's
second for the moment with fabi and
rajabov also having completed their
games right
and knockouts game is still ongoing but
um
is it ongoing guys i gotta interrupt you
before not playing whoa
wait for not play let's go guys
wait
wait wait no waiting let's see what
happens here d5 on the board
c takes d5 is forced right yes of course
all right then i assume rook c2 bishop
d6
bishop d6 you're not trapping my bishop
bishop d6 come on so the idea is that if
the queen what is the idea here if the
queen goes somewhere then you go b4 even
this the engines are like
what's going on d takes e6 still
possible remember this is not enough
six i stopped here
yeah i missed rook d7 oh yeah he kind of
goes on
whoa and what's going on suddenly the
engine says zero zero
queen c fox
i mean the bishop on a3 is trapped which
is why i was so happy
about slapping down the move bishop d6 a
time ago
it's craziness
uh d5 was a a crazy move by dude
i'm in a hammock
it's quite interesting i'm seeing naka's
face and he's thinking and he's like
shaking his head and he's
what's going on okay so once again hold
on uh i think you kind of got me
sidetracked there take on d5 yes let's
go forward now
recapturing's ridiculous that would just
allow my rook to uh take upon and attack
you
you have to play the move rooksy too
clear i dropped the bishop in
bishop to d6 now
you could you can take my queen i'll
take your queen and at the end of that
trade
we have to look at e4
even ed and knight f6 maybe sorry let's
just take a let's put it on the board
for just a second so take takes
and then ed and knight f6 you said i
guess right i mean you have to look at
it e4 you have to look at as well
but here
can i start eating yes
should we start eating should we start
eating b5 or maybe e5
maybe go b5 first because i don't think
e5 is going somewhere just yet and it
it's it's terrible that we can't
leverage our knight towards a checkmate
uh oh that would be so nice rook to e8
but this feels like it has to favor
white nah zero zero
come on
exactly exactly for those of you who
weren't here for it it was fantastic at
the grand chest store in bucharest
shaq uh won a game i think it was
against napo where he was just like
unbelievably fortunate like uh nepo kept
win missing
good move after good movie after good
move shaq comes into the studio and says
yeah hey guys i'm feeling really good i
think i i played a really good game
today
and then it was demonstrated that he was
lost on one move he goes oh really
and then another one comes and he goes
uh come on
i maybe had enough
come on uh
so let's go takes on d5 oh
so anastasia asks
magnus are you going to play neck nepo
magnus are you going to play nepo
we'll see we'll see we'll see
good for him good for him
all right we're going to take a quick
commercial break and we're going to see
you on the other side of this break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello
everyone and welcome back to our live
coverage of the 2022 candidates
tournament we are in round 13 and we
have three games already in the record
books one game remains that's the one
between hikaru and duda as you see there
but yan
nepo
winner our champion our champion our
challenger as he is unassailable with
nine points dingler and at the moment in
the clubhouse with seven waiting the
outcome of ikaro's game but this is what
it's all about
dorset becoming the challenger to the
world champion and our congratulations
for yon for playing an absolutely
absolutely marvelous tournament game all
eyes now on the game between hikaru and
duda when we were leaving we were just
in this position where we felt
that after the move d5 d4 bishop b2
e4 by duda he would be taking over
the game after all he is a pawn to the
good at the moment but he came up
with
a howler a mistake
he played the move d5 which allowed
this inter mezzo move bishop d6 seems
like he missed this move because it
like he reacted in a very strange way
there was a queen trade and now he
reacted in another very strange way he
played the move knight c5 which
is okay
and then came the move d6 intimating
that i'm ready to play d7
and then duda immediately
took his move back uh knight d7 which
definitely gives advantage white
now a big big turn around instead duda
had to play
knight takes d3 what else you're gonna
play d7
this rook moves
this knight gets captured and sure i
agree this pawn is scary you're going to
promote the pawn but
don't forget
that i have a bishop on g5
so that after you take at the end of the
day you have two pieces
a bishop and knight versus rook but look
at this
actually this is the scary pawn the a
pawn and i think it would be
up to white
to try to challenge to make a draw from
this position it didn't happen none of
this happened i'm really stunned by the
move knight d7 i think this just gave
advantage to
caro he's taken
and put his bishop on b4
and this is
huge alejandro this pawn on i'm looking
at the spawn on d6 and i'm thinking if i
was in white shoes i'd be thinking my
lucky stars
it's all the difference in the world
absolutely hikaru is in a dominant
position with this pawn on d6
it's crazy to go knight c5 and not go
knight takes d3 and it must have been
it must have been some
serious lap
in duda's mind here because he must have
felt that he was compelled to play
something along the lines of knight
takes d3 and then on d7
that he had to actually stick the rook
on d8 or something i don't know i have
to i don't know what he missed
instead of knight c5 because this i mean
i agree this is this is just okay
instead of knight c5 could you just take
the pawn maybe
yeah we analyzed this before we went on
break rook takes d5 knight f6 we didn't
give it to any real conclusion the
engines think that this is okay for
black but perhaps white is the one
pulling the punches but still with an
acceptable uh margin yeah just like
having that pawn on d6 is just so what
is it it's a torn in my eye i think
that's the horn
yeah well a snake on the throat but
you're absolutely right knight c5 d6
knight d7 no question about it
the presence of this pawn and now
even worse you know the extra pawn first
of all is not extra in fact these pawns
are weak and i do believe we have rook
takes e2 bishop b4
duda is facing
real
um
i want to say i mean he's on the verge
of losing his version
not just because of the position itself
but the trend right where's what's judah
done to his position in the last couple
of minutes he's ruined it imagine just
completely imagine
his state of mind right now he had a
good position he's had a horrible
tournament right horrible event
not put together two and two together in
many games and yet again he sits in a
position where three moves ago he must
have thought i'm up a pawn i'm better
i'm better on the worst case scenario i
can give it back for equality three
moves later he's here right on the verge
of defeat
bring yourself back together into the
game in a in a position of the
tournament where it doesn't matter
anymore if he finishes in his mind fifth
or eighth what's the difference right to
be fair i really did enjoy his nice
maneuver earlier in the game
but that was kind of about it
knight c6 all the way to f8 to g5 to e4
and it's the same night right yeah right
there's the knight on e4 that took on f6
man that knight just got to stay just
let that boy sit
well
having said all of this uh could you
give me an engine eval at the moment
it's only 1.5 oh no which to me is a bit
surprising i thought it was going to
explode into higher stratospheric
reaches meteorological c3 rook c7 is
such a compelling threat right so direct
and so strong that i'm surprised the
engine is finding a way to survive he
wants to play e4 it always wants to play
e4 but it does encourage
rook secretary c3 and now
it wants to play rook d8 again barely
holding on to the skin of its teeth
because rook c7 does come anyway and it
moves the knight says because knight d5
exists in so many positions
you have a hope but it's still rough you
know check here knight c6 pushes the
rook away i think eventually you're
gonna have to sacrifice an exchange the
thing is if you get moves like e3 and
you can play knight g4 perhaps you get
some compensation at the end of the day
yeah
so but he still has to make two moves
and he hasn't made it to 30.
how much time i'm in at 30.
and by this point it's a minute 20.
and taking and versus hikaru's
uh 12 minutes okay so no problem for
hikaru and he only has one move to make
oh you're right well i mean
i mean i can almost see him reaching for
his hand and pre-moving rook c3
and or you know pre-moving d6 d7 should
that knight ever
uh move away from d7 so practically what
do you think is a
safe choice he played bishop d8 he
played bishop d8 already it is one of
those
dia of bishop b6 you were talking about
counter play i like
your idea of counter play with e4 and e3
that felt much more direct this feels
like
rook c3 is coming you can't really do
much about us and
yeah just
this is kind of funny though um i can
almost drop in on the f7 square for
example i could give you a check right
let's just put that move on the board
for just a second
now i see that your bishop's coming here
and i'm thinking i would love to play
rook c7 but equally there's something i
find very attractive about getting my
rook to the d7 square because i in that
case let's just put a move on the board
it's a bad move and forgive me uh the
idea is that i'm i'm in a sense i'm
guarding
uh the pawn on
[Music]
f2
and i'm also ready to hit like something
like with knight g6 i'm ready to hit the
knight on d7 i think
uh
in hikaru shoes right here right now
i'm soaring i just i i have to keep calm
you know my nerves
uh but in this moment hikaru must be
thinking i have the best chance i've
ever had in this tournament
this is this time to shine right this is
hikaru's time to shine he's put himself
in a position where if he wins with
white what a chance he has at second
place and he starts wondering
is what magnus saying real and that is
what must be going through his mind he
needs to finish his game strong he needs
to finish it well if he wins today what
a huge chance he has just needs to hold
tomorrow against dingle ryan to claim
second whether that is going to amount
to anything that is for the future to
decide sure he needs to finish this game
well in order for that future potential
future to matter at all for him
you were right yeah sir in this position
after move 97 it is possible
but it doesn't really concretely put any
problems for white after the move king
h7
black's counter play is going to be
bishop bishop b6 and you were mentioning
this move rook here e4 rook f7 right but
it's still not clear what the rook does
immediately because i can kick it out in
with 95. yes d7 looks like it works
because rook takes you cannot play right
but after rookie chait kind of
surprisingly you've invited my knight to
d3 and remember this is hanging in some
positions when i kick out your bishop
not so easy also after 97 i know it
really is like swallowing a heart pill
but you can take
and make a light squid block bacon die
square milk this is a dark square bishop
right that ball might get stuck on e7
forever not so clear that you can push
it forward of course the engines get
advantaged white but much less
of an advantage because remarkable you
do think that this pawn might get stuck
so how do you make progress here there's
a couple of moves that jump to me i
think the human approach is this boom
that's your only active piece let's get
rid of it let's get rid of it
i like rook 3d too get rid of that
stupid rook it's the annoyance of the
sentry and then i can start thinking
about the move rook c2 to either c6 or
c7 start harassing your pawns my
advantage is not going to go anywhere
play it slow i like rook 3d2 that'll be
my choice the engines say rook c3 you
could look at bishop b6 rock c7 and rook
c7 i've been waiting to tell you that
but you have to calculate a lot here
because i have rook takes f2 you cannot
take on d7 rook f7 check picks up that
rook remember there's a check here so
you have to make sure that king h2 okay
kind of works but
are you so short
you this i know this rook is taboo you
never take the rook let me explain why
you never take the rook i would like
that if you take right away i have two
threats one is rook takes d7 and the
other one is to promote 97 check and
knight takes c8 the only way to defeat
against both is an ip6 but the moment
you start looking at this rook landing
on d8 or even this move bishop c5 you
realize
scary scary and dangerously dead lost
right so not no big surprise there that
taking that rook on c7 will always be
taboo and this is what makes white's
chances of converting so huge that you
actually have the access to this square
that just because there's a bishop on
the e8 it doesn't mean that the square
is covered so bishop d8 i like rook 3d2
the engines think just go for it forget
about it and then there's the other move
that i think is also pretty human get
out of the threats
go f3 and defend but hikaru goes for it
directly rook c3 on the board i'm sure
the bishop b6 will play by duda because
i don't see any other moves if this rook
lands to c7 with the bishop still on d8
game over lights out so i expect the
move bishop b6 will be black's 40th now
after bishop b6 is rook c7 kind of a
done deal is there anything else it
probably just transposes back i think
you're running out of resources to
defend this guy i mean you don't want to
play rook f1 fair
no no no
uh so you're going to give this pawn up
i think
okay
um well
once again uh just bishop b6 on the
board
rook c7
rook takes f2
yep this is our line
this is forced right yeah we're moving
our king presumably to h2 or h1 i'm not
sure matter that much okay and then
you've gotta more or less play rook f7 i
think work f7 and then you go check
okay
now you gotta give up an exchange
because a piece is hanging
right the interesting this is totally
one like oh
i was wondering why is it so winning it
just goes
here here and here
you can't do anything about it okay that
was very cute actually like bishop b6
rook d1 yeah only move that wins but
sufficient
followed by rook f1 and
that's game that's it
that's that's beautiful that's beautiful
that's good stuff that's a real geometry
that is bishop b6 and hikar has plenty
of time to figure this out he's going to
sit down on the board he's going to
think out something whether he's already
done it i do not know but he's going to
try to figure out how to win by force
he's got the time to do it he has an
hour
to figure this out because we just hit
second time control exactly he gets the
60 minutes this is the moment this is
the monte carlo fans want it
and
when you talk about one of the great
skills of fabiano being a great
calculator i got to throw in hikaru with
that too i mean that's really where in
my view both of those players really
excel maybe
above
just
maybe nepo's in that class magnus as
well of course magnus
it's just something special but
he's he's definitely looking at rook c3
and he's trying his best to
to to find a a win
and uh with these results that we've
just had uh dorsa uh the three results
let's take a look at our a live feed a
ratings how did today's games uh impact
well yan is um still well i feel like
they're pretty much the same but
fear is close to 2800 yeah yeah dang i
remember dingle is closer to 28 10 but
he dropped a little bit ago right yeah
he lost that huge game on the day before
the rest day giannis is still climbing
uh
i don't think he's i mean he's not going
to be able to cross 2800 here but
um very very nice and fabi is losing
just a little bit
another another one of our it's
remarkable with uh a rating of 2780 and
what i would describe is a disappointing
a very disappointing event for fabiano
only
that's him a loss of three rating points
that seems strange to me uh alejandro uh
only a three rating point loss despite
having um
bad uh well he's not 50 right
right
but
okay doesn't it feel doesn't it feel
like ugh
of course i mean if you're a fobby fan
this is like the biggest
disappointment ever when you have a plus
three score in round seven and in round
what is this 13 we finish around 13 on
50
right there was this half of the
tournament would have went
really really wrong when is the last
time that fabiano loses three games
without scoring or something in between
right uh
is incredible and we're talking about a
fabiano that was surging the one that
was on nepal's heels
if this result is hikaru wins today no
matter what happens tomorrow
favi is not in second place
exactly no you can't i mean it would be
impossible it would be impossible
mathematically impossible right so what
a disaster he has been for him because
yeah he's half a point for the ding if
nicaragua wins tomorrow he'll be on
seven and a half
and that's it since they play each other
one of them has to reach eight exactly
exactly wow
wow not a good day for bobby fan club
but
i mean good day maybe maybe we still
have to see if it may be a good day for
the hikaru fan club and
i mean again you you did make that
brilliant choice in nepo coming uh into
the second half but i'm very curious
guys
who chose hikaru
yeah baby that's what i'm talking about
nice choice jazz thank you
[Laughter]
cricket's around here
i mean
no voices in my ear no production uh
party hats
and there we have it again our current
standings with this one game remaining
i'm also looking at i just realized
flowey has not won a game in the second
half
exactly again the plus three result in
the first half the undefeated plus three
result of the first half
carried him
and nepo
he was nipping on nepo's heels i think
nippo
finished the first half with plus four
that's right yeah and there was uh favi
you know giving chase
and we thought you know the second half
what a great
event we're having and then fabi
disappears nepo holds his nerves
and remains undefeated and has won the
event
uh but it was really uh uh
a surprise a disappointment a great
disappointment to see uh
uh fabi fade as he did by the way king
h2
pointed on the board wonderful
clever intermezzo type of moves i don't
think it really makes a a difference if
you're planning rook c7 on your next
yeah that's what i was asking alejandro
too like what else can white do if not
rook c7 and he told me like even if king
uh it will all kind of transpose into
each other so
i'm hoping which kinds of
kind of begs the question
why exactly in this moment doesn't
hikaru start with the move f2 f3 if
bishop comes to b6 check and you go king
h2
um you know you're
keeping the the pawn you work sometimes
you have to work very very hard to win
upon
and sometimes you work hard to maintain
the pawn having said all of this the
more i
i love what you were saying alejandro
strategic chess you look around the
board and you say what is my best pieces
what are my opponent's best pieces oh i
know
the best piece that black has is this
rook on a2 let's get rid of it let's
just trade it off
and take care of all of the counter play
and then i'll slowly
figure out what to do next um very
surprising to my eyes that uh hikaru
actually played rook to c3
and
oops excuse me i don't think that uh i
think rook f2 is
analysis
uh king h2 is on the board
but having said all of this
has hikaru
correctly calculated a win
with rook c7 it looks pretty close to
over yeah rook takes f2
it's just that if you don't take one f2
i don't see a move that helps you true
right and where's the help
and this is
this is the variation
where we were calculating that nice rook
d1 this doesn't work geometry right
it's very pretty very pretty now
question after king is two let's say
black doesn't do anything do i like
black doesn't take on f2 do i still go
to c7 or can i just play f3 and key
exactly f3
keep your pawn but rook c7 one day
is on the agenda right i completely
agree right
is there any way i don't know rook a7 oh
that looks so ugly though
rook a7 i don't have to jump in
right away but
i do have f3 rook c6
nice ways of just prepping
further
invasion it's just it's just waiting
down it's just yeah yeah
uh essentially
with this decision to play bishop to g5
to d8
to b6
you're kind of committed to committed to
grabbing the pawn
on f2 don't you feel alejandro i don't
think there's an option and going down
that line that we saw it doesn't quite
work let's just continue on your
analysis board 97 take take
take on c7 take on d7 and now i have
bishop b8
now the difference between the other
variation and this variation is that
this idea of rook d1 it's not on time in
the other variation the king was on h1
ah
oops excuse me because you've got some
check and maybe
so to show our audience the difference
check
say king here
and i'm assuming that you have to stop
this
so you do it like this yeah and i start
pressuring
e7 right
small detail one tempo detail but it
doesn't work there are other ways for
white to of course try it's just that
the direct knight e7 doesn't have that
effect anymore
uh-huh
because the king is on h2 so the king
should have stayed on should have went
to h it's not a should it just changes
the variations that white wants if they
wanted 97 they would have put the king
on h1 hikaru is probably going for
something different
now there are plenty of ways to do it
right you don't have to play 97 you
could just play rook b7 and get the rook
out of
dodge
without 97. yeah uh sorry
another one that i was thinking of just
here
it's sort of like it it's positional
right i mean
the only if i play king e4 it's
positional overkill the bishop's dead
the rook's dead the king can't move
everything's dead so it's almost like i
was thinking
black's only chance of drawing the game
is to go e4 check
bishop to e5 and bishop to f6 and if i
could get my
king
uh to e4 because it was some way
again obviously e4 bishop bishop
rook to d8 king f7 yeah not so easy
right i'm not getting i'm not getting
that positional grip that i wanted
yeah it's probably not so easy for black
anymore from this position so again i'm
not expecting 97 if we do go down this
line okay
uh sorry
one last look here if i go here
check
king back bishop e5 or f4 i i you you
can decide later
i take
bishop here
rook here king here
i assume that
black can't move
okay right and can i
you know what i mean
i know what you mean easy-peasy uh get
the pawn why can't i move the rook like
what is the
issue
why can't you move the rook put it on c8
[Laughter]
you know
at one time there was a tactic
do they call it in farsi
the x-ray
the x-ray
i believe so
yeah and i didn't understand this idea
of the x-ray but this isn't a perfect
example the bishop on g5 does not attack
d8 it
but it does have an x-ray so in this
moment i'm ready to queen and checkmate
but rook takes and the bishop x-rays
this was called in spanish
x-rays same thing
say it again in spanish
nice translates well
i i remembered those eckies from
from uh mexico a mexican beer but okay
that's the interesting thing
in the world sorry you you you were
saying that there's a simpler way for i
don't know there was a simpler way which
was to play rook b7 i think it's just
more human just get the rook out of
dodge and then you can figure out if 97
works well if 97 feels like a huge
threat
in fact i don't really know what you do
against it let me put it to the engine
let's see rook takes f2 burger c7 rook
f7 all fours rook b7 all right one move
i mean it's plus three so it's very
winning oof ouch but only one move to
kind of survive king h7 so that's this
doesn't check
knight e7 anyway
bishop c5 somehow not dying just yet
rook takes i assume bishop takes c5
somehow holds right but takes takes rook
c7 is the engine solution
uh saying that this knight actually kind
of gets caught uh if you go this way d7
right okay no problem there you have to
go to a6
but any rook most rook moves including
rook a7 but even just cutting the um
cutting the knight
from the positions here and allowing
yourself to play d7 knight c6
the angels say it's just over
alejandro wow i'm looking at dude's face
he knows over you know it's very very
over but i have a uh
i have a very nice question for you
a very nice question very last question
so if i ask you to perform the three
typical facial expressions of a losing
play
[Laughter]
and we got this for posterity as well
alejandro
we've got pictures of ikaru that can do
that
magnificently well
i mean hikaru is a master chess player
not exactly a master poker player even
though he's dabbled
and we're being
told
let's go for it and by the way we've
been mentioning fabiano and
his phenomenal first half and his
linescore door said this says it all i
mean those three donuts in the second
half has killed his chances
poor guy hopefully he'll win the
tournament with a win
and he's and just think about that very
big
victory in round one he had uh remember
the players from the same country they
should match up as early as possible he
defeated ikaro
in the all-american derby in round one
yeah and then he got beaten up in round
eight that's the first big goose egg
that he has that's true sent him
spiraling i remember those days when if
you had people from the same country you
definitely wanted to separate it we
still have it in the rules just in case
you don't let people from the same
federation play on the last round of the
candidate section on the last two rounds
of the candidates so that there is no
collusion right but trust me
as you said
these guys
these guys are murderers
what's this an american should win no
way not you baby yeah yeah this one this
one went all out right i mean
got defeated in the first half came back
beat favi and
that's it that's all the matches that we
have with same uh players but it's also
happened in the 2021 candidates uh
alexandre against nepal nepoches
bang yeah
no no no friendly draws no friendly
draws whatsoever exactly king h2 duda
kind of a deep think right now trying to
figure out how to get out of this one
and i see on your screen you've got
a very
very dejected
uh looking duda as he's just kind of
like shaking and like
like oh oh dear the clear chest player
oh god well i mean he's thinking about
his move d5 right here right now because
a moment ago there was a black pawn on
d6
and
it was a very very good black pawn let
me show you where it was yeah it was
right here uh
his he could have played the move b4
driven the bishop back he could have
followed up with knight c5
and or
e4 and
he's in control he's got a very nice
advantage
instead he thought
d5 was a cruncher that it was going to
turn the tables decisively in his favor
he had foreseen this position in this
mind anticipated that the move b4 was
going to snare this bishop trapped his
bishop
and ikaru put bishop d6 on the board
and then after queen trade it's a mess
uh
carlos won his pawn back maybe caro's a
little bit better
and he followed up with this
howler knight c5 d6 and knight back i
just think here is like the last thing
if you come to c5 and then next move
you're like oh oh no no no no i'm going
to go back that's
right i don't think there is any come
back
it is weird to play knight
it's what we call the wily coyote moment
so we got uh the road runner the
roadrunner there's this cartoon and
there's this i remember this yeah
everybody seen the roadrunner yeah how
are you welcome
i mean i was just kind of explaining so
the idea was the coyote yeah he would be
running and then he'd be like
let's go backwards right so the knight
comes to c5
pressing forwards to attack the rook the
rook says
go ahead take me i want to play d7 and
then duda says no
i yeah i retreat and he so he lost a
pawn he lost
tempe
and the and the tables completely turned
and we're caught up with the players
right now and dude is sitting there
shaking his head
saying how could this pawn not be a
black
bond yep the poor kid i mean he's he's
not like he had the best tournament of
his life
trash tournament my god what happened to
duda if somebody had to say young
promising talent might surprise in the
candidates duda was no nowhere near to
be found like ali reza fell from a cliff
to the point where everybody's like oh
my god look at all the rest he's like he
fell off a cliff
but duda didn't do as badly and yet i
feel his tournament is even more
forgettable right he hasn't had good
chances the few good chances he had he
blew them he's turned really good games
into
into a loss there's no other way to put
it the game that he played against
richard rapport yeah was one of the
worst games of the candidates where he
puts his opponent's pawn on g5
purposefully and then he gets mated
right like what
yeah
the only thing i can counter with that
which makes it really
that much more
a strange outlier is he played a
brilliant game an absolutely wonderful
game against fabiano to send fabi you
know
down the slide yeah he played a great
spoiler against yeah that's what i mean
it was just amazing it's just amazing it
really was and then after that it's such
a quiet tournament
yeah very very strange we do have the
move king
h7 on the board i don't see
how that really changes white's approach
white still wants to play
rook c7 am i missing something does it
work though rook c7 take take knight b6
the difference is that now 97 is not
a check so can i just play pawn f3 i
really don't feel like giving up that
pawn i understand i uh
just
checking to make sure i don't have uh
a forced win because i do have a check
knight of
these guys can calculate
so incredibly incredibly well i'm sure
they would have no problems reaching
this point but maybe knight c8 knight d5
also right
knight d5 dang
i think that one either yeah i think 95
is okay
wow
okay um
that's much sharper than i
intended
and therefore i'm gonna go with dorsa on
this one
just keep it chilled just relax
f3 there's no e4 you can go rook c6
you're throwing that right you can do it
on your your yeah f3 i think f3 is good
you do it on your
time f3 must be the good move here i
mean you're not even down a pawn you
look at this position you expect white
to be down something
on the contrary he's not
not down material but all of his pieces
with the exception of the rook on a2
compare them to their counterparts you
go
you know you just down the line knight
g6 versus knight d7 the two rooks versus
the rooks the bishops and most
importantly this incredibly powerful
look at hikar you you asked alejandro
to do a
your
your losing look
this is hikaru like
with the eagle hawk
you know uh
a raptor mode
that i'm seeing at the board the eyes
are just ferociously darting around
as he's obviously he knows he has
advantage he's just trying to
just make sure he gets the full point
the easiest way possible no counter play
absolutely
yeah this one is dead dead guys come on
f2 f3 dead
yeah i i can't imagine i'm still saving
after f2 f3 what is
sometimes we play chess like this right
you're dead dead dead dead
and you think well
on some crazy day this happens
and i save it right what what is the
scenario
where's my
uh where's my plus
well i don't where's my cheapo where's
my cheapo that's right where's where's
my trick where's my saving grace where's
my by one tempe this kind of holds by
the skin of my where's this magical
fortress where's the
nothing right they're all back left with
knight going to c5 going back to d7 okay
i i'll throw something out there for us
so f2 f3 i think it's a great move
e4
why e4 i want to weaken the square g4
why do i want to weaken the square g4 so
i can go knight f6 knight g4 and make a
perpetual check
oh i see naka making his move nice and
f3 played
and he gets up to walk it's quite fun
actually
um
i don't know what to say
why it's just waiting for capitulation
at this point right there's nobody at
the board
it's not gonna happen
well dude doesn't want to rush he dude
is no in no rush to hurry back that is
for sure
and tomorrow is the last day
for our tournament here in the
candidates but we have plenty of chess
coming your way this summer we're gonna
have a two-day break yasser and i will
as we return with christian carrillo to
do the commentary on the u.s junior
senior sand junior girls championship i
think that one's missing you're leaving
us halfway through though i am i am
living halfway through
rat pink yes
i got to go to croatia look at that
croatia we got a date with magnus over
there
he will be joining the gct i'll be doing
the commentary there as well as the
interviews being gonna be pressing
magnus to see well you can you know what
by this point buddy you know who's first
and second are you playing or are you
not playing and of course he'll be
returning here for the sing-sing field
cup in september before the stingfield
cup we do have the gcd st louis wrapping
and blitz don't miss that one always a
fun event
no shortage of chess at all for you
spectators and i've heard that even
chess 9lx comes after this one so
no stopping at all uh just to clarify
magnus is going to play in the sinkfield
cup yes
and magnus is going to play in the
zagreb event as well that's right sweet
sweets oh my goodness
plenty of world champion in our gct
events i know the sing field cup is
going to be absolutely great we have
great players there the entire tour
participants fabi's going to be back
nepo is going to be back that's a big
one balireza is going to be back levon
aronia is going to be back magnus going
to be there it's a fun tournament guys
don't miss a party rook a7 played by uh
duda after f3 after f3 i think the move
rook c6 plays itself more or less
because 95's such a huge threat yeah
maybe there's other ways to skin this
cat but no rook c6 is uh
how about double and the rook
also i like that one too rook c1 rook
d1 to c1 and threatening to maybe rook
straight forward
and it's mate just
throw a dart pick a move
i like rook c won rook c8 just because i
mean i see that mate
in the corner there and i go wow uh
why is a knight so powerful on g6
because first of all it's protected
never forget knights love protection and
then this this natural mating pattern of
rook to h8 plays itself thanks to this
knight's
er
incredibly powerful presence so i like
this rook c1 rook c8 that that just
done
done see a few days ago we talked about
the different names for checkmates and i
looked at how i'm very new to learning
these names
now if i could get the rook to h8 is
that a dovetail mate
is that a arabian meat what type of i
always saw that the arabian mate was a
knight on f6
a king on h8 and a rook on h7 that was
the arabian mate but you know
could the knight on g6 and the rook on
h8 also be an arabian mate join the
conversation let us know i don't know uh
the
the name of that mating pattern uh
coach
you know jump in
there was this moment where i felt
really glad that nobody i was not part
of this conversation
i was in the same level as chess club
and they had this like beginner's boot
camp type of you know learning right
apparently you learned the names of the
checklists i never did you do i never
did i've never learned the name through
the checkmates i thought it was
completely relevant
when i learned that there were names for
checkmates i was already a gm like there
was no reason to go back and
listen to this and
one of the players that clearly also
doesn't know
the names of the checkmates but already
a grandmaster
you know this little
i don't know six seven year old comes up
to him with a question about his
homework
and the homework was something like list
the name of the checkmate yeah morphe
mate showed me a morphe there's like 2
500.
like completely clueless what is
supposed to have no idea i looked at it
i skadoodle before anybody asked me i
have no idea what any of these names no
clue if it's the whatever mate
no
clue at all
nice
uh i i just like the
vision of you know grand master grad
master could you please help me with my
homework what's a morphe mate get away
from me kid
you bothered me boy
oh
i think this is a hook mate which is the
scriptures
check my rook knight and the pawn along
with one enemy pawn to limit enemies
king's cape
i see that you've got them all listed
there the arabian-made the anastasian
mate
the back rank
the double bishop me
now what the heck was the dovetail mate
dovetail is a queen delivers mate on an
adjacent king whose only two escape
scores are obstructed by friendly pieces
you have to read that to me like 25
times before so
so the idea is black has a king on h6
and a pawn on g7 and g6
and you got a queen yeah so
oh well
now i've got to do something really
stupid uh you're not going to get there
i'm not going to you're not going to get
okay
this black king goes to the h6 square
what what this black king goes to the h6
square and you put this
pawn on g6 so you uh so you got a pawn
on g7 and g6 and a black king on h6 and
white goes
queen h for me
but thanks to the friendly
two pawns
it's a checkmate and that's the dovetail
mix yeah so it doesn't feel like i
thought that was something kind of cool
that's right it is what it is guys so we
have a move on the board ruby 6 what's
blade
okay hard to argue with that one hard to
argue with that one indeed and do that
man
i don't even know how he lasts too long
in this position i mean he's facing
knight takes e5 and probably amongst
other uh issues
but i do like the idea of doubling the
rooks and going rook to c8 as well this
looks really good i mean
yeah i mean you're skinning a cat
here different ways i'm so sorry why do
we keep saying skinny cats that is an
expression two cats we're all you got
two lovers
wait a minute i'm a dog lover right
i think you would you would still vouch
for no no cat skinny that's true i would
i heard it we're gonna drop it i heard
it twice oh come on we're offending
we're offending the cat owners here
you're right you say
i actually have no idea there's a lot of
idioms that i pick up from both maurice
and yasie
which you regretted they kind of stayed
with me i picked them one from christian
only time will tell but
trying to get rid of it
one of the things that was really funny
was during the 1972
world championship match
in reykjavik and iceland okay the
icelandic language is essentially
old danish old danish language
but it the the way the commentators it
was like
this ax destroys your pawn and you're
killed
by the bishop and you are fallen
to the rook so they had these really
brutal
ways of capturing violence and the
mommies of iceland were calling the tv
station and saying
my kids are being traumatized by your
descriptive language could you guys tone
it down
killing you and beating you and
destroying it
i thought it was hilarious that this
actually was taking place
um
how does he destroy
we gotta defend first
rook c6 sorry alejandro what you gotta
defend somehow as black first okay i
mean there is a very what am i defending
very clear three takes knight takes e5
just finishes the game i take off the
bishop and the pawn on b5 is to follow
but
if we touch the bishop i'm a little
worried about
potential rook c7s
precisely if you go bishop d4
for example just trying to anchor the
the bishop
then
yeah bishop to i'm just saying bishop to
d4 if we
if the bishop on b6
sidesteps okay right here this is this
is the moment and and white would like
to take this pawn on e5 right it takes
e5
and the knight which protects the bishop
would be attacked
so
if you
sidestep the threat what you were saying
dorset is that any bishop moves that
allow rook c7 you're ready
to make that move rook c7
and that looks incredibly powerful as
well alejandro i don't see
okay
there's not really much to do i mean
right it's been such a frustrating
tournament for duda but
yeah this game is just hopeless right
it's not just that there's a tactical
sequence that defends it
or ends it i'm sorry is that you don't
have a long-term defense your position
is just garbage i mean you have the
double pawns you left yourself with all
the strategical problems
you have a weak king you got the double
pawns white has a pass pawn your rook
has no penetration squares this king is
safe
it doesn't matter how you
uh what you do there will be a way to
end this game bishop e3 played
i assume roof c7 is winning for some
reason it's not in the top three of the
engine really
it's not but i bet you that rook c7 is
just as good
just as good yeah i think plus four uh
yeah plus four plus five i mean you
think you're good eyes that's that's
that's so that's a lot of pluses set up
pluses i mean how do you not play roxy
separately
i mean rx7 is so obvious but what's the
engine actually want to do
rook e1 and then take on e5 next move oh
no no i mean no
it's a move why
but my work is so nice when do you want
it doesn't matter i mean just nothing
matters anymore oh well
it's it's the stage of the game where
nothing matters well again just as you
were just describing the position a
moment ago all of black's pieces
including the rook that
had been sitting on a2 are defensively
placed like you're just trying to make a
blockade
you've got a weak e5 pawn you've got a
weak v5 pawn and your king is more
vulnerable so just like the
accruing all of these advantages in
white's favor
it doesn't surprise me that it's 4.4
some of the some of the evaluations
in some of the previous games were for
me really remarkable yes positions where
i thought ah you know it's a it's a
fight it's a duel
it's like three points
it's like what uh it doesn't surprise me
that this is a four-point advantage no
it surprises no one no no exactly
wow uh and for hikaru
you know we talk about a turnaround of
fabi fabi had this great first half
terrible second half
icaru's line score
is equally remarkable he started with a
loss
the first half was not going anywhere
really in his favor but then in the
second half and especially his game
eight
uh against oh we have a move
um
d2
one of the top engine moves
it was in round eight against uh fabi
that he won
that really put some wind in the sails
and it took it out of hobbies at the
same time
that's what he needed to do and he did
it top engine move huh one of the top
engine moves i think at this point uh
the engines are juggling to see which
variation gives the larger applause
because it doesn't matter they all give
such a huge plus at some point you're
determining whether you can win long
term or you win a rook and sometimes
winning that rook
he gave two pawns and then
if you counted it's only plus three but
in this one you're just kind of
finishing finishing finishing you can't
trade you just cannot trade why
because you run out of resources to deal
with rook c7 exactly you just can't do
it and if you move the bishop somewhere
where does it go if it goes to d4 if it
goes to c3 d4 bishop c3 is the same
thing you can't trade but if you don't
trade now you're going to lose material
now you're actually losing material by
force exactly because bishop c3 is not
possible so bishop d2 pretty much
finishes the game
we are expecting i'm expecting duda to
resign within the next three to four
moves ricardo looks like he's expecting
to do to resign right now
like i don't yeah
[Laughter]
i don't think i've done my job i think
he's right i think it's so it's like so
over that wow i wouldn't doubt do that
just three signs here
you know i think it takes a few minutes
for the the the part of this the guy
who's gonna resign to just kind of come
to terms with it and i feel like duda
has been coming to terms with it from
the facial expressions that i've been
seeing
but that makes me wonder
any uh any stories that come to mind
when you were on the winning or losing
side and you're waiting for your
opponent to resign and your their facial
kind of screaming
so what happened was um
i was playing
anatoly karp off the world chess
champion 1982 london the phillips and
drew tournament
and
i played a variation that victor
korchnoy had prepared for his world
championship match in 1980
and i was playing all of victor's
novelties and
karpov was responding
as if he had watched us
analyze the position he was playing
moves like this
and he sacrificed a piece and i couldn't
understand it it was just very very
confusing to me i thought i was winning
uh this peace sacrifice i i couldn't
believe it
and i'm looking at at karpov in his
perfect poker face like he doesn't
reveal anything i'm like
my god it's a piece i'm trying to
calculate and then his second
ethan geller came and was walking by the
table stopped
and reacted like like this is the worst
thing ever
and then karpov was looking at geller
his coach you know making these
looking at the demonstration board
looking
looking at karpov and karpov turned red
oh
so he knew he was busted of course he
did but of course but gallery revealed
and then i know ah
nice nice thank you that's
coming by just that moment
carpo was like get out of here you idiot
you messed it up what's happening in the
game alejandra i see moves have been
played
bishop d4 and bishop c3 as we expected
so nothing to talk about we already
talked about these moves bishop d4 on
the board bishop c3
games collapsing
[Laughter]
collapsing
i'm trying to remember
there was somebody who had resigned
prematurely
um
it was like in one of my open
tournaments
now i forgot the the gentleman's name
but
i thought he was offering me a draw
while he was
offering me his hand but he was
resigning oh
which was really nice because i didn't
see the wind oh so very recently i don't
know if you picked up on this alejandro
it was from the norway tournament
and viswanathan anand
had just played a move against shaq
shak mamidarov he moved his queen to b5
looked at what he did and in horror
realized queen takes f3 he blundered a
knight
and he resigned
without waiting for shaq to see it
and shaq didn't see it immediately
so he didn't have to resign necessarily
right you should let your opponent find
the move has anything like that happen
to you
alejandro were you
premature resigning by you or your
opponent
premature resigning i can't
i can only think of one time where my
opponent
resigned in a drawn position
very nice very nice it was it was a very
complicated
perpetual check that didn't seem like it
worked right but there was this hidden
idea that this bishop that was pinned
was actually defending like a key square
all the way on a3 right and my opponent
thought there's no perpetual time to
resign exactly and so he did but how
sweet how sweet very nice of him but
it's the only time i can think of so
another one this was really really
beautiful so it was uh
the 1997
gary kasparov man versus machine
deep blue kasparov they were in the
equitable building in new york city just
off of broadway
in the computer played this magnificent
game boom boom
and gary just absolutely resigned
in disgust
maurice ashley and i were calling the
action and when gary resigned we
explained to the audience
why the resignation was correct
i get back
to my hotel the michelangelo and there's
a an email from our friend jonathan
tisdale
tisdale writes me and he says yes sir
why did gary resign
he said you idiot he resigned because of
this
not so fast there's a perpetual in the
position
there's a perpetual check
holy smoke so i'm looking looking
looking and i discover that tiz is right
there's a perpetual check and that gary
resigned prematurely
so i went to frederick friedel
who from the chess based fame
who was
on gary's team
and i said to frederick that
kasparov resigned prematurely he said
what
and i explained to him everything that
had just happened with tisdale
and he goes oh my god that's incredible
yasser could you please tell gary that
he resigned prematurely i said no
so frederick had hailed a taxi
to take him down broadway and as they
were getting in the taxi frederick said
oh by the way gary yasser wanted me to
tell you that you resigned in a drawn
position
nice
gary froze
like just before he got in the taxi
instantly understood what
frederick was talking about and
frederick said
you could hear gary's cries
all the way down
broadway oh
no
it was terrible resigning prematurely uh
i think that's that that that's killed
just about everybody uh uh one time or
another
gary uh bishop
c3 uh sorry to
take us away from our game uh that was
it that was the last move yes nothing
happened
i'm out of stories
that has never happened in the history
of chess
wow uh yeah there's nothing premature
about resigning right now
so
we know dude as a fighter
but man it's hard to make moves here
exactly
yeah by the way isn't that his handle on
chess.com i think it's polish fighter
right polish fighter he changed it
recently did he yeah
what does he like about polish fighter i
think it was too long
hard to type in all the time
it was like the family actually had a
chest.com handle it was gm they're
probably actually but it's too later so
he took it gm off yeah
man this is like
very torturous for the polish fighter at
the moment right it's just such a
horrible event
and he compounds it he just keeps
compounding it
there was no reason to lose today
no i mean when you think about the the
strength of these players the strength
of these people there was no reason to
lose this game right
d5
men
it's such a suicidal move it truly but
good for good for hikaru fans because
yeah
finishes the game i assume rook c7
finishes the game
the one thing you don't want to do is
take on e5 prematurely and fall for
bishop f4 shaq that would be
you know
the greatest horror ever
oops
i think he carl sees this yeah i do too
uh but i love your rook d3 move just
putting the question to the bishop and
saying where are you going yeah where
are you going it's a funny question
right because the if you go to c1 it
actually gets hit
if you go to g5 then rook c7
c7 is such an auto i think that was
actually
white
c7 yeah rick's design was played
immediately okay
which we more or less expect yes
well i kind of expected bishop d3 to be
honest
uh rook d3 uh tickling the bishop first
doesn't matter what you what do you do
as black
i don't know i mean i'm not rookie 795
is a threat
yeah
a pretty strong threat that's really
strong it's a really strong threat so
you have to you have to react to it
right and you're
there's nothing right there's just
nothing well i was thinking ages ago
when the rook was on a2
to play pawn to e4 so i have this knight
g4 at this moment i just don't even see
a cheapo nope that's the thing that
we've been talking about for a few moves
yeah black is under such pressure that
there's no capacity to create a tactic
right this happens very often in chester
when you have a strategical dominance
over your opponent the tactics don't
work you cannot create tactics out of a
vacuum that's how the game of chess
works we've known this for ages and ages
the better position you have the more
likely it is that tactics work out for
you in this case
zero threats zero problems in white
structures zero problems with the king
and no surprise no tactics work out for
the black side he's played rook
ea8 to which hikaru thought for half a
second
play them with king h3
i guess bishop f4 is now no longer on
top not very difficult to explain the
move king h3 you're gonna be following
it up with knight takes e5 on the next
move yes you are and then
then it's the d-pawn express all the way
yeah king h3 looks very very
finishing uh touches finishing that's
all that hikar was doing right now
finishing touches he doesn't need to
take any more time he knows it he knows
that there's no counter play there's no
possibilities of even blundering he's
not messing around he isn't taking time
to figure out the best win here it's
done right of course
i remember
reading the two volume books uh by
alexander alekhine my best games
uh by the former world champion and he
was explaining that he was so tactically
gifted
that his problem was that he thought he
could save any position
through some
uh tactical means
and he needed to lose some gains to
realize that tactics don't just appear
by themselves
that you have to build up advantages and
he became
this incredibly well-rounded player when
he realized that tactics
weren't always going to save him that he
needed to in
learn
positional play and by the way um
i love
these biographies autobiographies and
books of best
i
gamepl
has influenced generations and i thought
it was a really really good series i
don't know did you ever
see it uh yourself
i believe so there was a specif but the
thing is like growing up i wasn't
reading the books in english i was
writing them translated to farsi so a
lot of things are
lost in translation
and um i remember like the first time i
wrote the
the the
fisher my sixth most memorable game i
read it in farsi and then i read it
again in farsi and then i read it in
english and i was like
this is a completely different different
book
the test was the same but like the
explanation the thought process of
everything was completely different yeah
we got we got lucky in spanish we have
really good translators back in the 60s
and 70s that took a lot of these books
and they translated not from english to
spanish which is where you get a lot of
problems when you do russian english
english spanish oh yes they did russian
spanish oh that's so nice and that
really helped out a ton of chess players
i read that i read those books in
spanish
i remember them very vividly i mean
those were the books that fell apart
right yeah yeah me too
that book had no chance right i mean it
was it was falling apart in 15 different
ways he had staples here i mean
that book was read
those two books actually yeah although i
i like the first version the first half
much better in the second okay uh but i
remember reading both of them until the
book just gave out i mean that that book
is actually no longer part of my
collection
because it fell apart it literally fell
on fire alarm if i'm not mistaken we do
have that in our in our slew chest room
we have a very a copy of it yeah we have
a copy but another one i used as a kid
that was one of the greatest compliments
i've ever received here at the club
there's this young boy probably six
seven years old he had his backpack mr
sherwin mr chairwoman could you please
sign my book he said sure do you have it
he goes yeah
my backpack and he goes up and he pulls
out
this raggedy
book man it looked like it fell in the
bathtub like four or five times the
pages were were all
brittle and everything i open it up and
there's notes on every page with
post-its and everything i said
you you you read the book
you're mr sharon i really liked it a lot
it was like this was the worst looking
copy ever
i wanted to give a new copy i signed the
book and it was just
it's so nice
when a reader reads the book like i
almost
consumed the book
my book came out in october so i haven't
had that happen yet
when it does happen it's very rewarding
yeah i still have my i have a few extra
copies so i still smell the new yes
there's got that new
new fresh
and of course we have this big winner of
our tournaments
she just won the candidates he's headed
to a world championship match we have
our reporter in madrid anastasia carlos
she caught up with the big winner
how do you feel except that you told me
right after that you were exhausted now
did you realize that you're actually a
winner of the tournament
i mean uh
i think i was more or less sure like
when having like two points advantage
with two rounds to go
but uh yeah the job had to be done and i
mean then we like
i finished quite you know quite quickly
the previous game and uh
of course uh it was
not so obvious of them until okay the
game between dingy and java was over
uh so i mean even
even though like with with these two
points advantage it was like
mathematically it was a chance to
screw everything up yeah
so um yeah i
couldn't really chill until
the game was over
and there he is and that's the way it is
it's not over till it's over i have to
mention because i've been doing some
math in my head so it's seven thousand
for every point yeah we probably need to
add up
the surprise total looks extremely small
but it's not that small guys right
so it's 63 excellent okay thousand
counting it could be another seven could
be another three and a half could be
right so
63 in the 48. yeah over 100. yeah
so
it's quite interesting for me that's
like there's a first place prize and
then there's a hey here's some extra
money i've never had anything like that
is that a common thing just for
candidates or
not sure
i've seen tournaments like that we have
had tournaments like that clutch chess i
want to say
was like that where we split up the
prices depending on how many points you
got there have been in the past
many instances of pl of tournaments
giving a reward for points made it's
very common also in leagues
that you get paid by the point i always
thought it was for wins not points to
like avoid draws or something like that
i've always thought of it as points i i
very rarely see it as wins you get you
get your prize for every half point i i
i
i remember in the u.s championships when
the price fund wasn't so heavy
they had top
eight prizes
and then they had point money
so for me this is
unusual i'm not used to seeing this i'm
i mean it's fine it's okay no problem
but uh also it's uh
a a bit
unusual again it's not common in my in
my world and of course they used to have
the brilliancy prizes but as well yes i
want a few of those playing you know
open tournaments and i love those
exactly it was actually the
one of the good ones i remember this was
a tournament i played in norway um
2016. uh it was like i played this kids
he was like 1900 that was 2400 i had
black it took me hours to win it and the
kids i i believe he's now a gm as he was
like 1900 but it's like by the end of
the year he was 23 20 and 400 so he was
like ready
yeah and like his chest was not 1900
obviously and it took me forever to win
it and because it was such a long and
fun game because i played something like
b5 the first movie
um
then
i won the the the the nice game up at
that round not the tournament i won the
the best game of the round for that one
but it was some money
so he didn't have to resign right and
then picaro took it for a guy ruby
every logical move i think i don't even
know if black has a threat
you could but
rook takes before is not a threat
because rick takes d7 right
yeah you're right a knight affair check
out i've got a knight f8 check
our producer
so i listened to the show realized that
i've been saying for the last hour that
if you throw a dart at every move you
probably win and he took a gander at it
he threw a dart said bishop c3 is the
best move bishop c3 played by hikaru
sorry and one of many ways of finishing
this game i think this one is the most
logical rook takes p3 rook takes d7 is
just completely winning among other
ideas if you take on b3 you could also
take on e5 nothing wrong with that you
could take on a7 and then take on e5
also nothing wrong with that you're just
choosing your win at the moment and if
you don't take on b3 why did you give up
a pawn
this is just over over
wonderful and uh by the way uh it was so
much fun uh presenting you all and thank
you for sharing your day with us all of
uh the guests that we've had including
gary kasparov always good to have uh
gary on uh for tomorrow we have another
very very special place
now or yes of course uh this
wanathondanan vishy
uh will be joining us to share his
thoughts a bit about these candidate
tournaments and potentially world
championship matches you know i if i'm
not mistaken again please everybody feel
free to help me out on the
logistics um i remember
i know that's um because chennai is
going to be hosting the olympiad in
a few weeks actually two three weeks
long alejandro getting on the floor
so i i do recall reading or and hearing
about how anand and everybody else and
in
the big people
in india uh started doing it the first
time
in forever the um the flame the old
people the torch yes thank you the
olympic torch for this year's olympiad
so i think that would be interesting
i'll definitely want to ask him about
that are you asking are you going to ask
him if he's still running with it
already yeah
the man started i think
[Music]
this is about 20 years ago i did an
interview with new in chess magazine and
they asked me
which country
would the world champion hail from in
2030 2030. in 2030
wow and i said india
they said well well well that was fast
how you can be how how could you be so
sure i said well how old is vichy
he just seemed to be getting better with
age at those times it's really
interesting like when there is that one
amazing chess player happens to be a
world champion everybody like that that
country's chess it becomes so enriched
it just goes up how many grandmasters do
they have every time i turn my eye
off to 72. every time i close my eyes
open there's a two new grandmasters i
shout out to sagar he's one of the best
most active definitely chess journalists
in the world the guy has been living
with his wife off of a suitcase
for the last i want to say three years
they actually had work non-stop maybe
three four years tournament tournament
during tournament to tournament non-stop
whether it's a junior event whether this
is the olympia the world championship
match a random tournament in the middle
of nowhere india for a regional place
doesn't matter he's there with the
camera interviewing people looking at
chess he has worked non-stop and he
always has a post on facebook when a new
gm arises in india sometimes that means
that he has three posts on the same day
because sometimes one tournament ends
and everybody got their final title
three different posts for them 72 i
think it's what the number is up to for
india from a country that in 1987
had zero
wow stop and think about that
do you think vichy had an outsized
influence
maybe she had a little bit of an outside
are we still confirming that it is
russia that has the most gms i think the
united states is up there too i think
for russia to be caught you need to add
up places two three four and five
double them i didn't realize it was that
oh yeah yeah russia has like 450 gm
something along those lines oh my it's
not it's not close i think goodness we
rated that nation for many gm's as well
right that's including the people that
have left right a lot of people have
left the russian federation of chess
recently
includes that
i mean america i think is up to 190 or
100 something along those lines germany
has a ton 90 or 100 serbia has a ton i
think those are the top nations if i'm
not mistaken i just want to interrupt
you to say we do have a tactic about to
appear on the board
[Music]
yeah i think that's the finishing
touches
wow where
yeah and when i think it's
is that right a hundred percent i mean
would you not say a hundred percent
right right right excuse me and we we
make it 110
yeah i mean
you don't need this vicario has one
wow it's over guys i don't know where's
second place in the candidates right now
who would have thunk this standings
after the first half hikaru hadn't won a
game dingle ren hadn't won a game
fabiana was plus three and tamer was on
minus two
and how the second half has flipped the
script completely except for one man jan
started winning and jan ends up winning
yana pomyacchi winner of the candidates
2022 this is our pairings for tomorrow
the duda nepomiaccia game is 100
irrelevant the only things we're going
to be focusing on tomorrow are going to
be the matches for second place and that
includes richard wait no it includes
nothing between richard rapport and
temura or karan against
it's all about thing and nakamura
because the people with six and a half
can no longer catch second
it's going to be entirely to see if the
chinese superstar with the white pieces
can finally topple the american streamer
or the world's number one chess
celebrity online will make his way to
second will whether that actually
guarantees a match we do not know that's
up to magnus carlsen to determine later
on in the year
you know that you want that second place
just in case
the only thing we know for sure is that
we do have a challenger and his name is
jan nepal
[Music]
as he wins the candidates championship
tournament running away
and uh for hikaru nakamura it's carpe
diem seize the day
absolutely as the romans would say uh
great
great
game and the only decisive game i want
to say dorsa
it was
uh
for
i'm
i gotta say it for dude fans it's really
disappointing now do they have that nice
night maneuver all around the board yeah
it was really really nice but he kind of
d65
by the way ended where it started
it's true
it's true
wait what was the root of this knight it
was c6 no no no it went to c6 first
knight b8 c7 that's right it went to c6
a5 c4 b6 d7 f8 h7 g5 e4 f6 d7 and died
on with a loss with a full tummy
on b8 what a route for the night but it
was not enough hikarna kimura crashes
through and that's all there is to say
about this round we are actually left
with an interesting final battle
tomorrow dingler and will certainly come
out guns blazing but that's all we have
left to talk about in this tournament
wow well yeah sir alejandro it's been a
pleasure working with both of you and
the production team tomorrow is
our last day
for now
for now
for now
but what an exciting day thank you for
joining us be sure to join us tomorrow
same time round 14 that we
we bring you the last round of the
candidates
and this swanathonda non vichy himself
will be joining us as a special guest
get your questions ready thank you have
a great rest of your evening
everybody wherever you're at
and we'll see you tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you